que vous avez
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce mardi 1er décembre
la police n'est ni violente ni raciste
déclarations du directeur général de la
police nationale auditionné cet
après-midi par la commission des lois du
sénat
frédéric veaux qui défend le courage et
le professionnalisme de ses hommes je
cite sans dénis alors que la majorité
veut une réécriture de l'article 24 sur
la loi sécurité globale le sénat de son
côté rappelle qu'il revient à lui seul
de modifier le texte lance sociaux en
cascade ou suppressions de postes au
sein de grands groupes avec un alibi
tout trouvé le coc vide
si la pandémie est mis en évidence les
faiblesses de notre modèle économique et
social le gouvernement invoque lui un
nouveau contrat social dans le cadre de
la loi pacte locaux vides peut-il
vraiment réussir à changer notre modèle
ou tout du moins obligé à le repenser ce
sera l'objet de notre face à face
[Musique]
aux etats unis le docteur aussi craint
une explosion en dés qu après les
festivités de france giving et les
déplacements de millions d'américains à
travers ton pays
les hospitalisations lieux humides ont
d'ailleurs augmenté dans presque tous
les états sur le fond la présidentielle
dans l'arizona le wisconsin la victoire
de baden est officiellement certifié
nous levons revers donc pour donald
trump et pendant que les négociations
post briques site se poursuivre tant
bien que mal entre londres et bruxelles
la première ministre écossaise réitéré
sa volonté de rester au sein de l'union
européenne
nicolas sur jaune qui a annoncé avoir
vouloir organiser un nouveau référendum
sur l'indépendance consultation prévue
le 6 mai prochain
[Musique]
mais après les différentes accusations
de violences policières et au lendemain
de l'audition du ministre de l'intérieur
à l'assemblée c'était donc au tour du
patron de la police nationale frédéric
veaux d'être auditionné par la
commission des lois du sénat
les précisions sur place de notre
reporter katia pique nique d'eric vous
le directeur de la police nationale a
été entendu pendant plus de deux heures
par les sénateurs qui voulait comprendre
dans quelles conditions la police
exerçait ces missions ils voulaient
aussi revenir sur les récents événements
et l'article 24 là frédéric veaux a
lancé un véritable appel à l'aide pour
la police en expliquant que la
proposition de loi sur la sécurité
globale
répondez à leurs attentes il a décliné
plusieurs éléments comme à nécessaire
rapprochement de la police municipale et
de la police nationale la montée en
puissance des sociétés de sécurité
privées et puis également la question de
la captation d'image vous propose de
l'écouter
la proposition de loi contient également
des dispositions très attendue par les
forces de l'ordre dans le domaine de la
captation d'image qui impose un cadre
juridique solide et respectueux des
libertés publiques
les dispositions prévues permettraient
aux policiers de travailler dans une
totale sécurité juridique avec les
moyens techniques les plus modernes et
selon des modalités qui correspondent à
leurs besoins opérationnels
je pense en premier lieu aux caméras
piétons dont le développement est
attendu par les policiers en quantité et
en qualité qui pourrait renvoyer les
images en temps réel vers les centres de
commandement mais aussi vers d'autres
prenaient policiers sur la voie publique
dans ce registre il me paraît également
indispensable que les policiers puissent
eux-mêmes consulter les images avec les
garanties qu'elle ne puisse pas être
bien sûr altérée par exemple pour
relever le numéro d'une plaque
d'immatriculation qui leur auraient
échappé pendant l'action frédéric veaux
a observé un niveau de violence et
d'agression contre la police inégalée et
donc
il a expliqué que certains policiers
pouvaient s'égarer à cause de cette
confrontation à une violence permanente
mais selon lui la police n'est ni
raciste ni violente et il souhaite
qu'elle soit protégée
sachant que les policiers qui ne
respectent pas les termes de leur
mission et bien sont sanctionnés pour
lui le lien de confiance avec la
population n'est pas abîmée beaucoup
moins que ce qu'en disent les médias
il a rencontré beaucoup de réceptivité
chez les sénateurs présents un autre ton
par rapport à l'audition de gérald
darmanin la veille à l'assemblée les
députés l'avaient plutôt bousculer sur
les questions de la violence et du
racisme dans la police est de l'article
et pour revenir sur cette audition nous
sommes en direct avec thierry clair
secrétaire général adjoint de sa police
bonsoir thierry clair merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france auditions
de gérald darmanin hier aujourd'hui
c'était le patron de la police un
soutien de votre hiérarchie à la hauteur
de vos attentes
écoutez en tout cas c'est un discours
qui va l'autre sens des moyens qui sont
demandés qui sont attendus par les
policiers de savoir qu'elle ne moral des
troupes n'est pas très long aujourd'hui
on a eu des jours difficiles qui se sont
passées une police qui s'est senti des
policiers qui se sont sentis stigmatisés
par une affaire sur laquelle on a fait
beaucoup d'amalgamés en fait on a tenté
de faire le procès de la police
et voilà donc il faut prendre en compte
effectivement ces considérations il faut
prendre en compte aussi qu'on a des
collègues qui seront été véritablement
violentée lors des manifestations samedi
en fin d'après-midi s'est traduit
d'ailleurs pas véritablement par des
lynchages de deux policiers
certains qui ont perdu des dents
d'ailleurs voilà donc c'est les réalités
du moment et je pense qu'il y avait
effectivement des annonces en tout cas
de soutien qui sont attendus qui était
attendu qui sont attendus mais également
qu'il se traduise ensuite par des moyens
il faut qu'on arrête systématiquement
chaque fois qu'il ya des manquements qui
peut l'être ou des diffusion d'image
qu'on fasse le procès de la police des
manquements il y en a eu il y en aura
quoi qu'il en soit ce sont des moments
qui sont marginaux dans qu'à des
interventions de police il ya plus de 3
millions d'interventions de police
quotidiennement donc c'est vrai que l'on
ne peut pas faire le procès de la police
systématiquement c'est le moral des
troupes qu'on atteint c'est le service
public de la police quand on atteint
c'est le rapport aussi entre la police
et la population
s'il ya des manquements et quand il ya
des manquements et quand il ya notamment
des images qui sont diffusées de toute
façon des procédures sont mises en place
que ce soit des procédures judiciaires
des procédures administratives
il s'agit pas de condamner les
fonctionnaires qui ont commis des
manquements est ce qu'il s'agit de perte
de sang froid de leur part parce que ce
sont des gens qui n'ont pas leur place
chez nous c'est assez lent qu'elle qui
le dira en globalité en tout cas ce sont
des décisions judiciaires
administratives dès lors qu'ils ne sont
pas prises en dalle sous la pression
médiatique de déterminant voilà donc
c'est vrai que ces images de la faire
avec l'art est clair en tout cas été
vous l'admettrez peut-être sans doute
absolument dévastatrice dans ce contexte
certains 10 et frédéric veaux
heureusement très peu nombreux mais
malheureusement encore trop nombreuses
ces gars en commettant des actes
contraires à la loi et au code de
déontologie
vous partagez tout de même ce constat
quelle a été votre réaction quand vous
avez justement vous aussi découvert ces
images nous on n'a jamais mis le
couvercle sur les affaires et je veux
dire les policiers n'ont plus on est
tout à fait conscient effectivement
qu'il peut y avoir des dérapages des
débordements il y en a eu il y en a il y
en a ras forcément le tour en fait c'est
de retrouver de la sérénité dans le
travail de prendre en considération que
les policiers font un métier difficile
ils sont confrontés à la violence
quotidiennement que d'ailleurs le nombre
de policiers blessés
il ya eu un article de presse la semaine
dernière ont été doublé en l'espace de
ces dix dernières années ça c'est une
réalité qu'il faut qu'il faut prendre en
considération
c'est un cercle vicieux la violence qui
appelle la violence des deux côtés non
mais les policiers doivent s'adapter
c'est pour ça que le métier est
compliqué qu'il est difficile non
seulement il est dangereux parce qu'on à
faire à toutes sortes de personnes me
faire bien sûr des missions d'être
d'assistance sur des individus qui sont
relativement dangereux sur d'autres dont
on doit déterminer effectivement
l'éventuelle dangerosité ou pas c'est
toute la complexité du métier on doit
faire notre assurer notre profession
notre service public en tout cas de
police dans ces conditions là et c'est
vrai que il y a aussi des lacunes dans
notre dans notre corporation et
notamment d'ailleurs nos ministres
on a fait tant en ce qui concerne j'irai
la formation continue la formation
continue dans les rangs de notre
institution qui est totalement
insuffisante qui n'existent quasiment
pas hormis les trois tirs le
réglementaire annuelle
la formation ne concerne très peu de
fonctionnaires et souvent quand elle est
mise en vente en place
c'est souvent d'ailleurs une contrainte
pour les policiers parce que le travail
en flux tendu tout le monde d'ailleurs
ne peut pas y participer et souvent ça
se traduit par des décalages horaires
donc voyez il faudrait véritablement il
ya des choses à moderniser
il faut que la formation continue et
s'inscrivent dans un parcours
professionnel
le premier policier bref que l'on
modernise la police oui qu'on ne fasse
pas son procès systématiquement dès lors
qu'il ya des affaires qui est des
moments où des abus c'est vrai que
gérald harman a évoqué la formation
aussi l'équipement de la police il a
aussi évoqué le problème de
l'encadrement pas assez de chefs et de
son chef
sur le terrain ce que vous partagez vous
aussi ce constat c'est vrai que on le
voit dans certaines grandes
circonscriptions en région parisienne
notamment deux jeunes policiers qui sont
d'ailleurs pour certains même pas
titulariser qui sont se retrouvent
quelquefois deux en patrouille qui sont
confrontées justement sur les missions
du service public police et qui n'ont
pas d'encadrement c'est vrai qu'il faut
remettre
il faut mettre je dirais et prévoir des
postes d'encadrement en tout cas sur le
terrain sur la voie publique
effectivement il y à ce besoin il ya
cette nécessité
il faut qu'ils aient un travail
collectif en fait qu'ils soient faits
par tous je veux dire tout corps tous
grades le tout le monde doit assumer ses
responsabilités et je dirais être aux
côtés en tout cas des collègues des
jeunes collègues notamment qui sont
confrontés à à mettre en application en
fait ce qu'on aura appris en théorie à
l'école à l'école de police mais je veux
dire confronter la réalité du terrain
les choses changent complètement et si
vous n'avez pas des fonctionnaires
aguerris autour de vous s'il n'avait pas
l'encadrement en tout cas qui vous
permet de deux de dire comment est ce
qu'on doit appréhender les choses
comment est ce qu'on doit faire comment
est-ce qu'on doit pratiquer dans le
cadre de nos missions
effectivement c'est bien ça devient
compliqué à propos de terrain gérald
darmanin ancien la généralisation des
et caméras piétons à partir de juillet
frédéric veaux elle a appelé de ses
voeux un port pour vous les policiers
déjà pourra-t-on les généraliser
parement ça ne marche pas très bien en
france écoutez on nous avons des caméras
piétons mais qui sont totalement
inopérant inopérante qui ne fonctionne
pas d'ailleurs qui ne sont pas utilisés
par les policiers parce que la charge de
batterie totalement insuffisantes
il ya des problèmes techniques pour la
fixation sur les tenues enfin bref tout
va très bien pour qu'on ne les utilisent
pas il ya nouvel appel en tout cas de
nouveaux marchés qui a été lancé les
carrières à piétons les policiers sont
favorables on n'a rien à cacher quand on
est policier quand on est au moins je
dirais que ça permet de contextualiser
l'émission est en tout cas par le sont
par l'image parce que c'est vrai que la
nuit la parole du policier
elle vaut pas grand chose aujourd'hui il
est très souvent remise en cause et
c'est vrai que moi avec la caméra
piétons ça sera quelque part une
protection pour les policiers mais aussi
à condition d'avoir du matériel qu'ils
soient opérant facile à utiliser et qui
sert avant tout cas qui servent
l'ensemble de nos collègues
merci thierry clair d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france et on en
vient à la pandémie de coronavirus elle
a profondément chamboulée d'économies si
de nombreuses tpe et pme ont mis la clé
sous la porte de grandmont compte
entrepris des plans sociaux en france on
dénombre la suppression de plus de 70
mille postes au cours de l'année 2020
selon les médias et syndicats mélanie
for nokia danone total general electric
bridgeston ces entreprises ont-elles
profiter de la crise sanitaire pour
procéder à des plans sociaux ces
derniers mois ils étaient des milliers à
défiler dans la rue pour sauver leurs
emplois
depuis l'instauration du premier
confinement en mars dernier l'économie
française et mondiale est mise à mal
avec une chute conséquente du pib si le
gouvernement a mis en place un plan de
relance de l'économie est octroyé les
mesures de chômage partiel à plus d'un
million d'entreprises
cela n'a pas empêché la multiplication
des plans sociaux
bien au contraire la gronde se fait de
plus en plus entendre du côté de general
electric ce mardi plus de 70 employés en
grève ont manifesté devant bercy et
l'assemblée nationale pour contester le
plan social qui prévoit la suppression
de 350 postes sur les sites de
villeurbanne et de saint priest près de
lyon
des multinationales qui se ferait sur la
vague kovy dix neuf c'est le sentiment
qu'on les syndicats ces derniers
demandent à ce que les subventions
versées par l'état afin de sauvegarder
l'emploi
certes à trouver une alternative au plan
social à béthune dans le pas de calais
les salariés du géant du pneu
bridgestone se mobilisent sans relâche
pour tenter de stopper la fermeture du
site qui entraînera la suppression de 8
163 postes en avril 2021
les syndicats appellent quant à eux un
durcissement du ton du gouvernement face
aux entreprises et aux multinationales
qui estime que la crise sanitaire est
une aubaine et une opportunité pour
licencier danone a bénéficié d'aidés
publiques et annonce des suppressions
d'emplois pour favoriser la
compétitivité rassurer les actionnaires
comme bridgestone les entreprises comme
danone sont très habiles pour faire leur
marché sur les aides publiques
c'est inacceptable il faut que le
gouvernement soit beaucoup plus strictes
quant à l'octroi des aides publiques
le 10 septembre dernier bruno le maire
avait assuré au sénat de vouloir
employer tous les moyens pour refuser
ces plans sociaux d'aubaine en appelant
les entreprises à faire preuve d'un sens
des responsabilités alors locaux vides
peut-il vraiment réussir à changer notre
modèle économique at on tiré les leçons
de la crise où la victoire du
capitalisme est elle inéluctable c'est
l'objet de notre face à face ce soir
[Musique]
et pour en débattre nous sommes avec
christian de boissieu économistes vice
président du cercle des économistes
bonsoir christian de boissieu merci
d'être avec nous à vos côtés pour
débattre henri sterdyniak économiste au
fc e membre des économistes atterrés
bonsoir henri sterdyniak merci d'être
avec nous donc l'insee qui prévoit un
effondrement de l'économie de 9 % en
2020 près de 10% de la population active
pourrait se retrouver au chômage avant
la fin de l'année c'est plutôt
inquiétant comme diagnostic
la deuxième vague du coronavirus
saura-t-elle mortel pour l'économie
française où on dramatise christian de
boissieu
les bobos les deuxième vague qui est pas
terminée et nous sommes encore dedans va
vous mali retarder la reprise c'est à
dire je pense que si une reprise en
l'année prochaine en 2021
elle commencera plus tôt au printemps
parce que donc cette deuxième vague
retarde est les possibilités de reprise
nous avons encore devant nous des plans
sociaux
nous avons comme vous l'avez suggéré une
montée du chômage
moi je pense que le chômage en france va
atteindre autour de 11% en mars de
l'année prochaine bien il ya des
faillites d'entreprises qui vont être
inévitable malgré les aides je dirais
les l'argent public et les liquidités de
la banque centrale européenne tout cela
ça ça limite la casse ça empêche pas la
casse et donc nous sommes dans un
contexte compliqué qui va rester avant
d'aller jusqu'au printemps et vous
disiez -2% pour la france en 2020
bon au moins neuf mois dix opéras mais
ce qui me frappe c'est que la france va
avec ce chiffre très négatif veille
probablement légèrement en dessous de la
moyenne de la zone euro
voilà quelques éléments khadra
alors dans ce contexte on vient d'en
parler les annonces de plans sociaux
inquiète évidemment illustration avec
danone qui vient d'annoncer la
suppression de 2000 postes en france et
à l'étranger regardez la réaction de
mini de l'économie bruno le maire je
demande aux entreprises de faire preuve
du même sens des responsabilités et de
considérer que la réduction d'effectifs
les licenciements c'est vraiment la
toute dernière mesure quand il n'existe
aucune autre possibilité est que la
situation économique est vraiment très
difficile pour l'entreprise à la
réduction d'effectifs c'est vraiment la
toute dernière mesure dit bruno le maire
vont trouver que c'est ce qui se passe
en ce moment reste armenia où on peut
dire que le coc vidal dos large
la vérité entre les deux bien sûr
regagnent une partie des entreprises qui
ont des difficultés financières donc
qu'ils vont être contraints de licencier
une partie des entreprises qui était
déjà en très mauvaise situation avant la
la pandémie donc naturellement elle
licencie on a des entreprises des
secteurs économiques dans lequel les
perspectives se sont fortement dégradées
par exemple l'aéronautique l'automobile
tout ce qui est tourisme événementiel et
on a un certain nombre de grandes
entreprises qui avait d'ores et déjà
décidé de restructurer des six décidé de
de délocaliser décidé décidé d'aller
produire ailleurs et ses entreprises
naturellement un profil de la crise pour
effectivement mettre en oeuvre ces
mesures a le le grand problème c'est que
ça arrive au moment même où forte hausse
du chômage en raison de la conjoncture
et on s'aperçoit bien sûr que ces
entreprises avaient planifiée depuis un
certain temps leur départ d'autres ans
la fermeture de telle ou telle usine et
ça pose la question effectivement
est ce que l'état les syndicats ne
peuvent pas intervenir en amont pour
éviter ce genre de choses à christian
voix sur cette crise du courant navires
us est ce que
finalement c'est la question qu'on s'est
souvent posé c'est le débat était lancé
tout au long de cette crise sanitaire à
ce qu'elle nous oblige à revoir notre
modèle est ce que le libéralisme est à
bout de souffle coûté en tout cas cette
crise
elle appelle une intervention massive
des états et je les lis tout à l'heure
une réactivité très forte du côté de la
banque centrale européenne alors l'état
je vais j'ai pas dire détail de retour
parce qu'il a toujours été là mais il ya
clairement avec cette crise la nécessité
de repenser de refonder et d'activer de
nouvelle politique industrielle
je prends politique industrielle au sens
le plus large c'est à dire l'industrie
ça représente 14% de l'activité en
france à peu près 15 % de l'emploi
quand je parle de politique industrielle
c'est beaucoup plus large que les 14 ou
15%
pour moi la politique industrielle ou
les nouvelles stratégies industrielles
ça doit concerner pratiquement tous les
secteurs le secteur des services
l'agroalimentaire est pas uniquement ce
qu'on appelle l'industrie au sens strict
du terme
si je peux revenir un mot sur le cac
danone parce que moi ça m'arrive en
partie dus et choqué pour la raison
suivante seco danone c'est la première
grande entreprise française avoir pris
le nouveau statut d'entreprise à
missions proposées par la loi pâques la
loi pacte a été adoptée en 2010 et 9 et
7 loi propose à certaines entreprises de
définir en quelque sorte leur mission de
manière beaucoup plus large que la
question de la rémunération correcte des
actionnaires c'est à dire le entreprises
à mission ça donne un signal fort de la
part d'une entreprise comme quoi
l'entreprise se veut citoyenne veut
aller bien au delà de la recherche de la
rentabilité financière à court terme
donc je trouve ça quand même un peu un
peu paradoxal qu'une grande entreprise
comme danone ap
après avoir pris statut d'entreprise
démission se met comme ça annoncé des
centaines de
sentiment c'est qu'en france et je
termine en disant que derrière
l'intervention de l'état
votre question lol je répète la mise en
place massive de dead le chômage partiel
les prêts garantis par l'état tout ça
moi je pense qu'il fallait il faut le
faire quand il ya le feu dans la maison
on appelle les pompiers
les pompiers et son ex vient
d'identifier aujourd'hui mais dans ce
contexte là je dirais la question des
contreparties est importante
une entreprise comme danone a bénéficié
bénéficiant encore de dead variés du
côté des états je pense que le sujet sur
les contreparties à demander autant
d'entreprises presse intulée qui restent
sur la table
surtout christian de boissieu que
l'entreprise a distribué 1,4 milliard
d'euros cet été à ses actionnaires
regarder précisément comment le patron
du groupe alimentaire emmanuel faber
s'en est expliquée il va peut-être vous
répondre indirectement dans les colonnes
de libération la semaine dernière à
cause de la chute de 30% de notre cours
de bourse depuis le début de l'année et
les 100 euros investis dans danone il y
à 12 mois par un actionnaire ne valent
plus que 70 aujourd'hui il nous a semblé
très important de faire en sorte que nos
actionnaires touchent sur d'excellents
résultats 2010 9 ce qui leur revenait
une entreprise ne tourne pas sans
actionnaires henri sterdyniak actuelle
actionnaires il fallait qu'ils
récupèrent voilà ses bénéfices de 2019
votre réaction votre réponse le principe
c'était actionnaires sont là en principe
des risques vis aurélie réponde des
risques
il ne rentre là dans une situation tout
à fait paradoxale où les entreprises
considèrent que quoiqu'il se passe il
faut absolument rémunérer les
actionnaires et à la limite plus une
entreprise se porte mal mieux et nous
rémunérer les actionnaires pour les
combattre de rester dans l'entreprise
c'est tout à fait c'est un épiphénomène
tout à fait pervers au clar la crise
actuelle montre plusieurs choses d'une
part c'est qu'effectivement l'état joue
un rôle extrêmement important
d'assureurs et donc l'état illégitime en
quelque sorte pour influencer plus
directement le
l'évolution les choix stratégiques des
entreprises il fait choix stratégiques
doivent être pensés à moyen terme ce qui
veut dire qu'elles doivent être
négociées réfléchi avec que les pouvoirs
publics mais aussi avec les syndicats
des des choses comme bridgestone ou les
syndicats découvre que effectivement le
plan de l'entreprise cette aide permet
lusine c'est tout à fait c'est tout à
fait inacceptable et bien sûr la
question qui va se poser après la
pandémie
on va avoir l appareil productif qui
aura extrêmement abîmées il faudra
repartir il faudra que l'état pilote la
lah nouveau départ de l'économie
française en tout cas suppressions de
poste d'un côté la bourse qui se porte
plutôt bien
de l'autre on va regarder quelques
chiffres on s'est amusé à faire une
petite courbe tout ça en plein sur les
vingt dernières années au moment de la
bulle spéculative regarder dans les
années 2000 le cac 40 qui était assis
1944 point la crise des subprimes de
2008 3217 points et la 5581 points c'est
pas trop mal tout de même christian de
boissieu on nous dit voilà il ya une
énorme crise économique va y avoir 10 %
de chômage - 1 1 % en 2020 vous le
disiez vous même tout à l'heure vous
pouvez nous expliquer avec des mots
assez simple voilà cette différence
qu'on a du mal à saisir quand on n'est
finalement pas un expert comme vous
coûter il ya clairement une certaine
déconnexion entre la bourse du lait est
ce qu'on appelle l'économie réelle celle
des connexions qui existe donc depuis un
certain temps elle est clairement
alimentée par la politique monétaire par
les banques centrales qui injecte
massivement des liquidités je répète
nécessaire d'injecter massivement des
liquidités mais la contrepartie c'est
que on revit dans un contexte où les
taux d'intérêt sont proches de zéro
quand ils sont pas négatifs
et les liquidités massivement injecté
dans l'économie se retrouve quelque part
et donc à une partie ses liquidités qui
vient alimenter ici ou là des bulles à
l'heure et dans certains cas ça peut
être des bulles sur l'immobilier je
parle y'a pas une bulle immobilière en
forme de manière générale je veux dire
il ya des marchés immobiliers est
certain c'est marché du mobilier il peut
y avoir des phénomènes de bulles et sur
les marchés d'actions je pense que
l'abondance de liquidités résultant de
la politique monétaire par ailleurs à
mon avis nécessaires c'est un mandant de
liquidités e10 droit alimente alimente
les placements en actions dans un
contexte où je répète beaucoup de
placement rapport pratiquement rien ce
que je suis en train lire n'est pas
totalement incompatibles ou mail est
même compatible avec le fait que quand
vous regardez les chiffres
vous avez une augmentation de la
collecte du livret a en france
parce que depuis mars il ya eu beaucoup
d'épargné additionnel à peu près 90
milliards d'euros
du côté des ménages français et que donc
une partie de cette épargne sur trouve
en liquidités par exemple livret a bon
mais ça n'empêche pas que par ailleurs
dans ce monde où il ya beaucoup
d'activités une partie niant s'investir
sur les surcoûts sur les bourses sur les
marchés d'actions henri sterdyniak le
mot de la fin ça veut dire d'une
certaine façon cette confiance est
illustré par la bourse allait d'une
certaine manière un petit peu artificiel
où elle illustre quand même
effectivement plutôt une bonne augure
pour l'avenir est la bourse fonctionne
avec des hauts et des bas actuellement
on à l'ours qui est extrêmement triste
par rapport à la situation réelle parce
que il ya la perspective de trouver à
dax a donc tout le monde se dit ça va
permettre de redémarrer donc la bourse
va monter donc j'achète donc
effectivement ça fait monter la bourse
par ailleurs la plupart des le marché
s'attend à ce que les taux d'intérêt
restent très bas ce qui est également un
facteur qui fait monter la bourse donc
que la bourse est
ce qu'on appelle auto validante auto
réalisatrice donc on a cette montée qui
est tout à fait excessive la bourse n'a
perdu que cet ouragan ancêtres n'a perdu
que 7 tours sort depuis le début de
l'année alors que les perspectives
économiques se sont quand même
complètement se sont beaucoup assombri
donne c'est une bulle c'est une bulle
qui va perdurer parce que les taux
d'intérêt vont rester très bas sauf s'il
y avait une catastrophe du genre les
vaccins ne fonctionne pas ou ne
troisième une quatrième dingue mais
actuellement les vagues et les matières
sont prises sont trop optimistes
merci en tout cas à tous les deux
christian de boissieu henri sterdyniak
d'avoir été avec nous pour évoquer et
donc cette version version jeu versant
économique de la crise sanitaire merci à
vous de rester avec nous dans quelques
instants nous partirons aux états unis
alors que les autorités sanitaires
craignent une explosion des cas trop
vide après les festivités de fancy
giving et puis nous parlerons de l'école
la première ministre réitère sa volonté
de rester au sein de l'union européenne
est d'organiser un nouveau référendum
alors que des négociations post break
site se poursuivre
[Musique]
m
comment choisissez-vous un film un
projet un scénario un réalisateur avant
de choisir en ait choisi ce qui fait le
propre d'un acteur c'est de partager des
sentiments des idées des émotions
vous vous êtes vraiment dans le cinéma
de créateurs d'initiateur je crois que
le cinéma c'est comme la peinture c'est
comme le la littérature ça reste un art
peut-être que maintenant c'est
l'industrie qui gagne mais du coup
peut-être que ce qui va rester c'est que
les films qui seront de plus en plus
fait pour le cinéma et pas sur les
grands réseaux resteront des objets
artistiques
c'était godard qui disait cette chose si
forte quand on regarde la télévision en
baisse les yeux quand on va au cinéma on
lève les yeux
tout est dit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
20h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct sur
rt france aux états unis le recomptage
des votes de l'élection présidentielle
se poursuit hier deux états clé ont
confirmé la victoire de joe biden
l'arizona et le wisconsin un nouveau
camouflet pour donald trump qui ne cesse
d'accuser le candidat démocrate de
fraude
mathilde romagnan c'était les deux
derniers territoires clés de cette
élection
l'arizona héloïse caunes sinon recompter
les voix de leurs électeurs et confirmé
la victoire de joe biden dans chacun des
deux états une défaite symbolique pour
les républicains
lowy scan ci n'avait voté
majoritairement trump en 2016 et
l'arizona bascule dans le giron des
démocrates pour la première fois depuis
près de 25 ans voter est l'un des droits
est l'une des responsabilités les plus
importants de notre démocratie et je
tiens à remercier les habitants de
l'arizona d'avoir fait entendre leur
voix et d'avoir voté en nombre record
les votes ont été compilés les quinze
comté ont tous certifiés leurs résultats
dans la foulée les partisans de donald
trump sont descendus dans la rue comme
ici à phoenix capitale de l'arizona pour
soutenir leur candidat les recours du
président sortant devant les tribunaux
ne sont pas terminées en arizona il est
possible de contester les résultats même
après validation
pour ce qui est du risque on signe trump
balaie ces résultats d'un revers de main
le recomptage du winsconsin n'est pas
fait pour trouver des erreurs de
comptage mais pour trouver des personnes
qui ont voté illégalement et cette
affaire sera portée devant les tribunaux
une fois le recomptage terminé lundi ou
mardi
nous avons trouvé de nombreux votes
illégaux restez connectés
les avocats de donald trump ont déjà
contesté les résultats électoraux en
arizona en géorgie dans le michigan le
nevada et dernière étape en date en
pennsylvanie
des recours rejeté à chaque fois celui
qui est toujours locataire de la
maison-blanche multiplie les coups
d'éclat ce dimanche sur la chaîne
conservatrice fox news
il a même accusé le fbi d'être mêlé au
scrutin c'est de la fraude
et c'est tout quant au fbi au ministère
de la justice je ne sais pas il se
pourrait qu'il soit mêlé à ça c'est tout
de même incroyable que tous ces gens
puissent en tirer comme ça avec la
fraude qu'il y ait eu partout personne
n'est venu me voir pour me dire au fait
le fbi a coincé les auteurs de cette
machination tout cela alors qu'une
échéance cruciale pour le pays approche
le 14 décembre les représentants de
chacun des 50 états américains devront
formellement procéder à l'élection du
candidat démocrate
si le choix jo bèye 2 n'est confirmé
l'ex-vice-président de barack obama
entrera en fonction le 20 janvier
prochain est toujours outre-atlantique
cinq jours après la fête de thanksgiving
c'est la crainte d'une flambée des
quatre co vide elle immunologue anthony
facci est mis en garde dimanche contre
une forte hausse de la courbe des
contaminations en raison des réunions de
famille et des voyages la société
américaine moderne à l
débat déposé hier son demande
d'autorisation son vaccin contre le
comique 19 les autorités examineront le
dossier en urgence le 17 décembre une
semaine après celui de pfizer
la campagne de vaccination pourrait
débuter avant les fêtes aux états unis
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
jean-claude beaujour vice président du
cercle de réflexion france amélie
bonsoir jean cau bonjour merci d'être
avec nous alors fait divines où l'on
craint un rebond de l'épidémie comme les
autorités sanitaires elles ont affirmé
vous le craignez aujourd'hui c'est un
vrai risque que l'on a aux états unis
c'est vrai que la fête du thanksgiving
est l'une des fêtes les plus célébrées
aux etats unis c'est un grand moment de
ce côté de l'atlantique les uns et les
autres se retrouvent en famille alors us
et a dit j'ai constaté que les uns et
les autres avaient aussi fait preuve de
prudence beaucoup de mes amis m'ont dit
ben nous serons à 2 ou à 3 donc beaucoup
de prudence
il semble que les principaux messages
notamment aussi ceux venus de la
communauté internationale sur la manière
de traiter le coc vide est porté porté
leurs fruits
mais malgré tout on peut redouter que
des rassemblements familiaux
surtout lorsqu'on a parfois de très
grandes familles puissent d'être des
kloster pour le court aux navires us des
rassemblements familiaux vous dites ya
eu la prudence mais tout de même au
moins un million cent mille personnes
ont pris l'avion dans la seule journée
qui a précédé la fête de thanksgiving
jeudi dernier c'est un nombre record
depuis le début de la pandémie est ce
qu'il aurait fallu peut-être les
empêcher les autorités auraient dû
prendre des mesures nécessaires comme le
fait d'ailleurs emmanuel macron il a
parlé d' empêcher les personnes aidées
afin d'essayer les dissuader d'aller à
l'étranger faire du ski est ce que les
autorités auraient dû faire ça aux états
unis selon vous alors pour répondre à
votre question je préciserai simplement
que c'est un million sur 350 millions
d'habitants aux états unis voyez
finalement c'est très marginal en
sachant que ce chiffre habituellement à
cette période de l'année est quasiment
dix fois plus important c'est vraiment
une très grande fête c'est la fête
la plus importante de ce côté de
l'atlantique est ce qu'il aurait fallu
empêcher les populations de se déplacer
savais qu'ici aux états unis avec tes
pieds précisées par un certain nombre de
responsables politiques qu'ils ne
devaient pas y avoir qu'il n'allait pas
y avoir de confinement généralisée
autoritaire un peu comme à la chinoise
oublier à la française c'est un choix
politique qu'il faut respecter
est ce qu'il aurait fallu faire
autrement mais ça seul l'avenir nous le
dira si effectivement le nombre de bleus
le l'explosion du nombre de couronnes à
virus est plus important que ce que il
aurait pu que lécher les chiffres en
tendance exponentielle n'aurait pu le
laisser prévoir alors la question c'est
toujours la même comment va tenir
l'hôpital est ce que l'hôpital aux états
unis d'une manière générale alors gagné
50 états ont le sait mais l'hôpital
va-t-il pouvoir faire face à cette
éventuelle flambée on nous annonce alors
il y as que l'hôpital va faire face va
pouvoir faire face et puis surtout les
moyens qui vont être déployés n'oublions
pas qu'ici même s'il y a des hôpitaux
publics il y à de l'aide qui est
apportée par aux plus démunis il ne faut
pas oublier que le coûts hospitaliers
sans commune mesure en tout cas celui
qui facturés aux patients est sans
commune mesure avec ce qui se pratique
en france où et d'une manière générale
en europe ce qui veut dire que cette
situation sanitaire risque de laisser
sur le carreau un certain nombre de
familles qui pourront peu sait-on jamais
vendre leur maison leur action vendre un
peu de leur patrimoine pour pouvoir
essayer de survivre à ce patrimoine
cette crise sanitaire donc on voit bien
une situation hospitalière que nous
connaissons mais aussi une situation
humaine une situation de crise
économique pour un certain nombre
d'américains dont on sait bien que
certains ont perdu durablement leur
emploi effectivement le futur secrétaire
au trésor a affirmé ce soir la crise
économique actuelle est une tragédie
pour de nombreux américains
ça veut dire que joe biden devait
certainement récupérer un pays
totalement à reconstruire ça va être
très compliqué pour le nouveau président
des états unis
alors j'ai presque envie de vous dire la
malchance pour l'amérique mais et la
malchance pour joe biden c'est qu'on a
le sentiment qu'il rejoue 2008
souvenez-vous que lorsqu'il est arrivé
aux responsabilités avec bara
obama il y avait la crise économique et
le gouvernent le pouvoir du moment avait
du très rapidement période de transition
prendre des mesures l'appareil joe biden
n'a pas le temps d'attendre la fin le 29
janvier il est obligé de mettre en place
un certain nombre de mesures pour
limiter ce qui s'annonce comme une
catastrophe épouvantable parce que vous
savez que aux états unis certains nombre
d'emplois dépendent de l'activité
véritablement réel réel ou au quotidien
ce sont toutes ces personnes qui sont
chauffeurs de taxi qui sont qui
travaillent dans les hôtels qui
aujourd'hui sont sans emploi et donc
qu'ils sont privés de 80 90 % de leurs
revenus
même si ici ou là des aides peuvent être
apportées elles sont sans commune mesure
ici n'est pas question de rester chez
soi et de recevoir 70 % de sa
rémunération
donc vous imaginez très bien que la
situation est extrêmement difficile sur
le plan humain
l'équipe de transition l'a déjà compris
c'est d'ailleurs pour cette raison
qu'elle s'est tout de suite mise au
travail sans même attendre la
reconnaissance de l'élection en tout cas
d'avoir gagné l'élection par par donald
trump elle s'est mise au travail parce
qu'elle sait qu'elle n'a pas le temps
d'attentes dès le 20 janvier elle devra
prendre un certain nombre de décisions
drastiques alors elle a peut-être bien
fait parce que donald trump lui n'est
pas vraiment décidé à reconnaître la
victoire de joe biden joe biden qui a
été déclaré victorieux dans l'état clé
notamment de l'arizona c'est certifié
pourtant donald trump continue
d'affirmer qu'il ne changera pas d'avis
sur ces accusations sans preuve de
fraude électorale
on a du mal de plus en plus peut-être à
comprendre ce que souhaite faire mener
le trump
vous savez en tant qu'avocat je dis
souvent que un justiciable a le droit de
prétendre avoir le droit deux donc c'est
le président des états unis qui est
encore donald trump a parfaitement le
droit de contester une chose est
certaine c'est qu'il y à des
institutions qui fonctionnent qui ont
montré qu'elles fonctionnaient donc les
recours il peut exercer ses recours
jusqu'au 8 décembre c'est à dire qu'il a
encore une semaine pour pouvoir purger
pour que ces recours soit purgée à
partir du 8 décembre dès le 14 décembre
il y aura la réunion des grands
électeurs et à partir de ce moment là je
crains qu'il ne puisse plus faire grand
chose
et en main la décision de la cour
suprême de pennsylvanie
je peux vous dire qu'elle est sans appel
ou la cour on reconnaît qu'il n'ya pas
de manoeuvres de nature à pouvoir et
valider les résultats en pennsylvanie
alors même je vous le rappelle qu'en
pennsylvanie
il y avait pas moins de vingt grands
électeurs en jeu si la pennsylvanie a
les recours ont été rejetés en
pennsylvanie en arizona ça sera ça sera
le cas je crains que ce ne soit que des
déclarations mais malheureusement qu'il
ne rencontre pas ceci qu'on soit pour ou
contre donald trump il s'agit là d'une
réflexion purement juridique
je crois que ce soit juridiquement
désormais sans issue alors donnent à
leurs hommes qu'ils essayent quand même
un petit peu tous les recours à un
dernier événement en date la cour
suprême qui a examiné hier la décision
du président sortant d'exclure et sans
papiers du recensement de la population
cette dernière requête de donald trump à
la cour suprême quelles pourraient en
être les conséquences
vous savez c'est celle là encore la
quelle que soit la décision de la cour
suprême ce qu'il faut bien comprendre
c'est que un juge est à paris tu as
regardera si la décision qui a été prise
a un impact électoral politique de
nature à inverser les résultats dans
l'état concerné imaginez qu'on parle de
la pennsylvanie est ce que cette
décision peut avoir pour conséquence des
versets les résultats en pennsylvanie il
faut regarder là au cas par cas
je crains que ça ne puisse pas être le
cas et donc malheureusement que ça ne
changera quoi qu'il en soit que les
résultats généraux et à paris tu as ne
seront pas complètement changé et donc
le résultat en nombre de grands
électeurs et quasiment qu'on se
consolider à moins de 15 jours
désormais de la réunion des grands
électeurs merci merci
jean-claude beaujour d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur un écran ce pour
parler de la situation du kobe de aux
états unis mais aussi la situation en
politique merci à vous merci à vous
en irlande les six semaines de
confinement partiel sont enfin terminés
les magasins dans essentiels tels que
les gymnases bibliothèque salon de
tatouage et musées ont ouvert depuis ce
mardi
premier pays d'europe à agir pour
contenir la deuxième vague en imposant
un confinement dès le 21 octobre dernier
dublin a rapidement vu reculer le taux
de reproduction du virus en soit risque
évident
cela faisait six semaines que le centre
ville de dublin n'avait pas connu une
telle affluence depuis ce mardi musée
galerie marchande cinéma bibliothèque
lieux de culte peuvent enfin rouvrir
tout comme les clubs de gym les piscines
ou les magasins non essentiels à
l'instar des salons de tatouage une
réouverture dans une ambiance assez
étrange
l'ambiance est très bizarre
il ya des volets fermés tout autour de
moi ici pour ces gens je ne sais pas ce
qui s'est passé mais il s'est passé
quelque chose pour qu'ils ne rouvre pas
c'est triste c'est vraiment triste
c'est la vie d'une personne qui investit
dans son entreprise
et c'est peut être fini pour elle les
restaurants et pubs servant à manger
pour mieux accueillir de nouveau les
clients à partir de ce vendredi
mais à la même table ne pourront pas
être servi les personnes de foyers
différents qui ont toujours interdiction
de se mélanger
cette restriction majeure tout comme
l'interdiction de voyager en dehors de
son comté ou à l'étranger sauf pour le
travail sera néanmoins levé du 18
décembre au 6 janvier pour les fêtes de
fin d'année entre ces dates jusqu'à
trois foyers pourront alors se réunir à
l'intérieur
des scanners ça ne peut pas être et ce
ne sera pas le genre de noël auquel nous
sommes habitués
mais ce sera un moment très spécial où
nous pourrons tous profiter d'un peu de
répit face aux difficultés de l'année
2020 et de ces dernières semaines en
particulier
6 le gouvernement et moi-même sommes
convaincus que cette combinaison de
nouveaux arrangements établir un
équilibre sur entre le maintien de la
pression sur la maladie et la création
d'un espace pour que les familles des
amis et les êtres chers soit ensemble à
noël dès le 7 janvier au matin le pays
retournera alors aux restrictions en
vigueur avant le 18 décembre
des restrictions qui seront réévaluées
fréquemment en fonction de l'évolution
de la pandémie
une pandémie qui a tué plus de 2000
personnes dans le pays soit presque
moitié moins qu'en france une fois le
chiffre rapporté à la population les
négociations post break site à présent
se poursuivent dans la capitale
britannique à moins d'un mois de la fin
de période de transition
londres et bruxelles qui comptent de
surmonter leurs divergences sans
parvenir à un accord de libre échange
sans quotas ni droits de douane en cas
de nos deals le gouvernement britannique
a reconnu de probables perturbations à
court terme à la frontière est averti
des millions d'entreprises des défis à
venir et la première ministre de
l'écossé elle veut rester au sein de
l'union européenne
nicolas star john key à annoncé hier
vouloir organiser un nouveau référendum
sur l'indépendance consultation prévue
pour le 6 mai prochain lors d'un premier
référendum en 2014
55% des écossais ont voté en faveur d'un
maintien au sein du royaume uni ajouté
qu'il est mieux que celle ci au royaume
uni la menace du président se profile à
l'horizon dans un mois à peine les
causes sera contrainte contre notre gré
à une relation beaucoup plus distantes
avec nos amis de l'union européenne le
choix de l'indépendance est important de
plus en plus de personnes en écosse en
sont persuadés et je crois passionnément
que cela aura le pouvoir d'unir un pays
indépendant ou ceux d'entre nous qui
vivent ici façonnent l'avenir et
travailler ensemble pour surmonter
les difficultés sera bon pour nous tous
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis londres avec martin mc colis
analyse politique c'est notre rubrique
vu de l'extérieur ce soit bon soir
martin un mec colis merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france la première
ministre convient d'entendre un qui dit
vouloir organiser un référendum en cas
de victoire de son parti aux élections
locales de mai prochain ce sont les
vieux démons qu'il surgisse pour la
grande bretagne
la première mini qu'elle avait perdu le
dernier référendum et depuis elle a la
tête ça encore encore qu'elle en veut un
deuxième pour le moment beaucoup de
sondages montrent que l'indépendance a
le vent en poupe canticel l'expert de
premier rang des sondages a dit que cela
n'a rien de certain
on ne peut pas prendre cela comme preuve
que l'indépendance serait gagnante et
d'autre part à londres doit donné sa
permission afin qu'il y ait un
référendum pour le moment pour iphone
seul le premier ministre britannique est
d'inonder le parti national écossais va
remporter les élections et va remporter
des autres élections en car il est clair
que c'est eux le parti numéro un projet
qu'on les joue pour le moment les cos
est divisé l'un des problèmes majeurs
c'est la monnaie a déclaré écosse
indépendante regarderai la livre
sterling
mais cette livrée garantis par la banque
d'angleterre dans une école indépendante
la banque d'angleterre ne pourrait
soutenir garantie
la livre écossaise donc la livre et
qu'on cesse d'appeler sa valeur la
difficulté majeure à laquelle est
confrontée l'ecosse et pour le moment il
n'y a pas de solution vous nous dit en
substance que l'ecosse n'auraient pas
les moyens de son indépendance
facilement l'économie ne se porte pas
très bien et l'économie pétrolière car
il ya de larges réserves de pétrole à
aberdyn se porte bien
mais les prix du pétrole ont chuté et
les prix ne suffisent plus aujourd'hui à
financer l'échiquier écossais le des
finances écossaise le problème et
d'autre part qu'aider mme bourette un
centre financier majeur et beaucoup de
services financiers des banques à
edimbourg pourrait quitter la ville ce
revenir vers londres ou vers
l'angleterre à cause d'une livre
écossaise très basse donc c'est un
problème supplémentaire
du point de vue économique les
perspectives ne sont pas très brillantes
mais nicolas sturge n 10 que l'ecosse a
été indépendante dans le passé et
qu'elle peut donc être indépendante à
nouveau avant le 18e siècle elle était
indépendante donc elle pourrait l'être à
nouveau
mais il n'est pas certain que les causes
ce soit de pense accepté comme et
indépendant car par exemple la catalogne
en espagne pourrait demander à
l'indépendance et ensuite à rejoindre
l'union européenne
donc du point de vue européen il est
également possible que l'ecosse ne
soient pas acceptés comme nouveaux
membres européens
alors on l'a dit tout à l'heure en 2014
un référendum avait déjà été organisée
les écossais avaient voté à 55% pour
rester au royaume uni vous nous disiez
tout à l'heure que les sondages étaient
un petit peu inversée en ce moment sans
préjuger évidemment d'un résultat final
comment expliquez vous cette tendance
qu'ont les écossais aujourd'hui à
l'indépendance demeure la première
raison c'est que boris johnson le
premier ministre britannique qui est
très impopulaire en écosse on le rend
responsable du fiasco de lakovic 19
c'est le mot qu'ils utilisent il me met
en cause sa gestion de l'épidémie
toutes ces actions sont considérées en
écosse comme anti écossaise et beaucoup
d'échos c'est aujourd'hui disent nous
voulons partir à cause de boris johnson
l'autre question c'est les écossais qui
vivent en angleterre devrait-il avoir le
droit de voter parce que par exemple
lors d'un lord élections récentes en
moldavie les moldaves bien qu'ils
vivaient à l'étranger ont pu voter
mais du point de vue écossais du point
de vue de nicolas stade jeunes il serait
dangereux de leur permettre de voter car
une majorité d ecosse vivant en
angleterre préférerais que le royaume
uni reste unie et donc ils ne voteraient
sans doute pas pour l'indépendance si le
référendum avait lieu demain et borie
justement sur devrait l'accepter
alors je pense que le résultat serait
bien plus serrée qu'auparavant cependant
il est très probable qu'une petite
majorité ferait qu'ignorer pas
d'indépendance vous dites contre boris
johnson et contre bolton et sombre
excite surtout c'est surtout le break
site qui fait certainement peur à
beaucoup d'échos ceux qui ont envie de
rester peut-être dans l'union européenne
tout à fait il considère le bric sitcom
un danger pour les cosses économiquement
et politiquement
l'ecosse a voté pour rester au sein de
l'union européenne et le royaume uni
dans son ensemble a voté pour le départ
l'ecosse souhaiterait rester au sein de
l'union européenne et donc tout accord
du breakbeat est considéré comme une
catastrophe économique pour les causses
et les écossais souhaiterait une
compensation en dédommagement il
préférerait qu'il y ait un nouveau vote
au niveau du royaume uni sur le pré exit
un nouveau vote afin de voir si les gens
ont changé d'avis par rapport au dernier
référendum en 2016 il est possible que
la population souhaite maintenant
rejoindre le royaume uni mais je pense
rejoindre union européenne mais je pense
que les écossais se trompe car le nombre
de personnes au royaume uni qui votent
pour le maintien sein de l'union
européenne à mon sens a baissé mais ils
écosse bien sûr considère toujours cela
comme un désastre économique pour sa
propre économie
merci beaucoup martin mc cauley d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur arte france
pour vu de l'extérieur ce soir merci
donc quelques instants rester avec nous
ne reviendrons sur la réforme des
retraites un débat inapproprié pour le
secrétaire général de la cfdt laurent
berger une priorité absolue en revanche
aux robes renaud lemaire et puis nous
parlerons du coc vide emmanuel macron
qui lance une campagne de vaccination
grand public entre avril et juin
[Musique]
nora lakehal a été la première femme à
intégrer le groupe
islamisme radical de la saur c'est
l'élite des renseignements généraux de
la police française
c'était après les attentats du 11
septembre et quand on vient vous voir et
qu'on vous dit ben écoutez vous avez de
la première femme qui allait rentrer
dans ce service
vous ne pouvez absolument pas refusé
votre mission première est celle de
traquer ces terroristes ce prêcheur
salafistes il vous a des tranchées pour
reprendre un code policiers il vous a
reconnu qu' pas voilà pour moi c'est
fini pour moi est ce que ça remet en
armes
tout est passé dans ma tête est ce que
vous avez appris de ces profils
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont chercher
d'ailleurs dans la religion le profil
vient toujours de la misère sociale
quand on écoute comme ça du majeur mais
quel est le rapport avec la radiation
mais fait la radicalisation
il faut que nous reprenions la place
dans le cerveau des enfants et de la
jeunesse
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité
on est comme tout le monde même si on
n'est pas en appartement et hervé
grenelle sentiment qu'il faut à chaque
fois se battre ils vivent parfois au
bord des routes nationales pas forcément
loin de paris mais toujours loin de ceux
qui les dirigent
majorque mâcon il passe un tour de
tracteur avec nous trois campagnes il
faut savoir c'est une différente
ils ont le sentiment d'être des français
de seconde zone comme s'ils étaient
invisibles
marc pourrait t'aider à peu plus
aujourd'hui la france oubliée c'est
montrer ce qu'on ne voit jamais
[Musique]
et
quand vous voyez ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui avec cette deuxième vague
avec ce deuxième dauphine mans est ce
qu'on pouvait faire autrement plus vous
dépister - les jambes et ça a été vu en
allemagne quatre fois moins de morts
qu'en france ça a été vu en autriche 4
fois moins de morts provence a été vu en
corée du sud etc
ça ne profite pas de cette deuxième
confinement pour dépister
systématiquement de les choses vont
recommencer
il y aura une troisième vague au
printemps et un troisième confinement et
ce pays sera évidemment cloués au sol
certains disent que nous sommes pas une
chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons
la liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
la chasse est un lobby donc il pèse très
lourd il faut arrêter de dire que on a
besoin des chasseurs on a besoin de
régulation on n'a jamais eu la preuve de
ça cette réduction du débat justement
entre le tout blanc a le tout noir ne
nuit-elle pas finalement à l'idée même
que les français pour espère de la
chasse je crois pas que ça soit réduire
le débat de rappeler qu'au sien un
plaisir qui va jusqu'à la mort cc c'est
ça l'essentiel et c'est pour ça que
c'est un sujet très très épidermique
parce que s'ils une histoire de vie et
de mort il faut protéger la végétation
faut protéger la faune il faut protéger
notre santé
tout ça c y et n'oublions pas tous nos
problèmes viennent du mépris qu'on a sur
le reste du monde vivant donc il faut il
faut arrêter de laisser les chasseurs
faire leur bêtise et je suis poli
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi qui ait des candidats pas
intervenir au sort du public
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous l'uniforme c'est quand même des
hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas la ligue
parlementaire
ça se passe en direct puisque on est on
dirait qu'il y a quand même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs sont joués mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp les pions
prennent la place des rois de films
stratégies peuvent porter des résultats
inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
je suis les chômeurs et chaque semaine
dans l'échiquier mondial nous
analyserons les coups les plus complexes
du jeu politique internationale
[Musique]
à bientôt sur rd france
21h heure française merci de nous
rejoindre pour cette deuxième heure
d'émission tout de suite voici les
titres de l'actualité de ce mardi 1er
décembre la réforme des retraites de
retour sur le devant de la scène un
débat inappropriée prévient le
secrétaire général de la cfdt laurent
berger alors que le ministre de
l'économie bruno le maire veut lui en
faire une priorité absolue estimant
qu'avec le retour de la croissance
étaient un des facteurs qui permettront
à l'état de rembourser la dette issue du
coc vide est toujours en france emmanuel
macron visage des mesures restrictives
et dissuasif pour les français voulant
skier à l'étranger à noël le président
qui annonce une campagne de vaccination
grand public entre eux avril et juin
l'union européenne se prononcera
d'ailleurs sur l'autorisation du vexin
pfizer by one tech au plus tard le 29
décembre au karabagh environ 2000
soldats russes de maintien de la paix
sont sur place pour garantir l'accord de
cessez le feu
c'est dans le cadre de cet accord peu
l'armée azerbaïdjanaise est rentré dans
le district de latchine dernière des
trois rétro concession rétrocession
téhéran continue d'accuser israël
d'avoir assassiné le scientifique mort
scène
maxi
dès le physicien eu droit à des
funérailles nationales hier il aurait
contribué à la reprise des travaux sur
un programme nucléaire à possible
dimension militaire
le mossad est directement visé par le
gouvernement iranien
[Musique]
le débat sur la réforme des retraites
loin d'être enterrée manifestement en
pleine crise sanitaire le mini de
l'économie remet sur la table ce dossier
explosif au grand dam des syndicats de
l'opposition de droite comme de gauche
du medef ou encore de la ministre du
travail bassin chebbi un agenda social à
haut risque pour l'exécutif
et voilà que le projet de loi sur la
réforme des retraites refait son
apparition dans un contexte d'urgence
sanitaire les parlementaires craignent
un risque de tensions avec le retour de
ce projet de loi annoncé par bruno le
maire le ministre des finances qui a
jugé cette proposition de loi et cette
réforme des retraites comme priorité
pour 2021 la réforme des retraites est
morte née car ceux qui l'ont porté son
démonétisé il y a trop de tensions
sociales dans ce pays
ma conviction profonde c'est qu'il n'y
aura pas de réforme des retraites sur ce
quinquennat
bruno le maire serait bien inspiré d'en
parler avec tous ses collègues
le ps ne veut pas voir revenir après la
crise sanitaire une réforme qui étaient
déjà mauvaises avant la crise il serait
profondément indécent de revenir à cette
réforme de régression sociale une
priorité absolue pour bercer qui fait
même grincer des dents côté syndicats la
priorité du moment c'est la relance
économique la cohésion sociale la
question de l'emploi et du chômage
il faut se concentrer là dessus on est
encore dans ce moment où on investit
dans l'avenir on n'a pas la mesure de
tout ce que cette crise a produit sur
les systèmes sociaux
on a suffisamment de tension aujourd'hui
il faut traiter les questions quand elle
se pose la dette c'est trop tôt sortons
de la crise avant toute chose si ce
dossier revient sur la table
il donnera lieu à un conflit social
l'urgence est de retrouver du boulot
le medef de son côté préfère jouer la
carte de la montre temporiser là où
bruno le maire a plus royaliste que le
roi voulait mener à bien cette réforme
quitte à tacler le syndicat patronal sur
la droite
l'état nounou et l'économie
subventionnés ont atteint leurs limites
la réforme systémique des retraites
devra attendre un peu
on ne peut pas demander aux partenaires
sociaux de tout faire à la fois pour
bercy toutes les excuses sont bonnes
pour faire passer cette réforme
explosive
quitte à accélérer le calendrier et
faire porter le fardeau aux français
déjà bien éprouvée
et les divergences se font même sentir
dans les rangs de la majorité
une position vis-à-vis de laquelle
elisabeth bornes et la ministre du
travail et son collègue chargé des
relations avec le parlement ont préféré
prendre de distance
la priorité absolue c'est de sortir de
la crise sanitaire économique social de
protéger les emplois c'est l'avis
unanime des partenaires sociaux il faut
trouver un chemin pour reprendre les
discussions avec les partenaires sociaux
pas avec le 49-3 comme cela a été fait
en première lecture à l'assemblée avant
l'éclatement de la crise sanitaire
la réforme des retraites visait à avoir
plus de justice et l'anglais sur la
question budgétaire ne me paraît à ce
stade pas la question croissance contre
justice sociale bruno le maire n'aura
jamais autant été isolé dans ce contexte
politique économique et sanitaire ou ce
projet de loi sur la réforme des
retraites ne semble pas être à l'ordre
du jour les divisions sens même du
gouvernement on en parle avec alexis
poulain c'est notre rubrique l'édito
[Musique]
bonsoir avec sia poulain merci d'être
avec nous alors qui croire au
gouvernement sur ce sujet des retraites
est ce qu'on parle d'un cafouillage de
plus je sais pas si c'est un cafouillage
où une stratégie d'à côté bruno le maire
-ministre de l'économie qui veut montrer
un du volontarisme dans cette réforme
systémique des retraites pour bien
montrer que la france est une bonne
élève et rassurer à la fois les marchés
et les institutions européennes qu'ils
commencent à s'inquiéter 1 du taux
d'endettement français ou bien elizabeth
bornes qui elle est du côté des
travailleurs et dit attendons la
croissance attendant la reprise de
l'activité pour remettre cette réforme
des retraites sur la table je crois que
chacun est dans son rôle et qu' il faut
malheureusement croire tout le monde
sachant qu'un arbitrage devrait être
fait en haut lieu
et visiblement compte tenu de ce qu'on
dit les partenaires sociaux se
pencherait plutôt du côté de la ministre
du travail de dire attendons la reprise
de la croissance attendons de voir
quelles seront les chiffres du chômage
avant que de remettre cette réforme
systémique sur la table
et qu'en pensent les partenaires sociaux
et bien eu comme s'était dit dans le
reportage sont en bloc contre le retour
de cette réforme des retraites
compte tenu de l'incertitude devant
l'activité économique
compte tenu aussi des nombreux plans
sociaux qui se sont accumulées depuis le
premier puis le deuxième confinement
même si l'aide de l'état est là pour
aider les commerces et des entreprises
elle est parfois insuffisante elle ne
n'évitera pas de nombreuses familles
failli de tpe de pme ou des plans
sociaux même dans dans l'industrie qui
paiera de toute façon une reprise lente
même si encore une fois bruno le maire
se veulent optimistes pour 2021 donc la
france va rebondir très fort ça reste à
voir
alors pas les mêmes avis de part et
d'autre qui croire
c'est en fonction que vous êtes
financier vous préférez croire bruno le
maire qui va pousser rapidement cette
réforme qui était dans les cartons des
manuels macron dès son arrivée à
l'elysée
et puis si vous êtes du côté des
syndicats du côté des travailleurs et
bien vous préférez croire la ministre du
travail qui parle le bon sens en réalité
cette réforme ne peut avoir lieu sans
l'accord majoritaire des partenaires
sociaux et des syndicats qui aujourd'hui
ont très bien compris que ce serait une
explosion sociale programmée que de
remettre cette réforme extrêmement
contestée déjà lors de son premier
passage avant la crise sanitaire
ce serait une folie politique que de
faire cela alors autre patate chaude 1
du gouvernement l'article 24 de la loi
sécurité on en parle tous les jours en
ce moment que souhaite un rien
finalement emmanuel macron après les
grandes manifestations et les violences
du week-end dernier sauf que le
parlement lui rappelle un ses droits les
sénateurs en tête
alexis oui alors c'est ce fameux article
24 qui veut encadrer la façon dont le
l'image des policiers seraient utilisés
de manière malveillante sur les réseaux
sociaux
cafouillage total déjà au sein de la
majorité qui a voté pour le texte de
sécurité globale y compris l'article 24
mai rétropédalage devant le tollé auprès
des associations de défense des droits
de l'homme avec un ministre qui ne sait
plus comment faire un premier ministre
qui parlait même d'une commission ad-hoc
pour réécrire l'article et puis des
parlementaires de la majorité qui ont
dit mais attendez nous nous sommes
parlementaire c'est notre travail
d'écrire de loi laissez nous faire notre
travail
et puis cette loi maintenant arrive dans
les mains du sénat le sénat à majorité
plutôt l air et eau entendent bien
s'approprier cette loi l'amendé la
réécrire enlever toute référence à la
loi sur la liberté de la presse de 1881
et il y imprimer leur marque pour
retoquer ou un ré écrire mais à leur
façon avec la navette parlementaire tout
simplement cette loi qui finira de toute
façon sous les fourches du conseil
constitutionnel donc pourquoi vouloir
outrepasser encore une fois le jeu
parlementaire c'est assez symptomatique
de ce quinquennat ou l'exécutif prend
toute la place et laisse bien peu de
place au législatif
merci alexis poulain la crise du
coronavirus en france et les derniers
chiffres santé publique france dénombre
8083 cas de kobe détecté en 24 heures en
léger recul par rapport à mardi dernier
365 personnes sont décédées à l'hôpital
le taux de positivité des tests
s'établit désormais à 10 8% et poursuit
sa baisse il ne les gère tendance donc à
la baisse qu emmanuel macron tombe bien
préservés pour ce faire mais aussi pour
éviter une concurrence déloyale il
annonce envisager des mesures
restrictives et dissuasif pour les
français voulant ce qui est à l'étranger
à noël pour rappel les remontées
mécaniques des stations françaises sont
pour l'instant fermé jusqu'au 20 janvier
le président annonce également une
campagne de vaccination grand public
entre avril et juin écouter lors d'une
conférence de presse dans le cadre sa
rencontre avec le premier ministre belge
il y aura une première phase qui
commencera dès que possible c'est à dire
des qui aura eu homologation des
autorités sanitaires européennes et
fourniture des doses dans nos pays
on voit bien entre fin décembre et début
janvier vraisemblablement il y aura une
première campagne de vaccination qui
elle sera très ciblé avec des vaccins de
première génération sur lesquels on a
peu de recul dont les conditions de
conservation et logistiques sont assez
complexes - 80 au moins 20 degrés à ce
stade des conditionnements et qu'on va
plutôt réservé sur l'ailé en tout cas
les publics les plus sensibles
ce ne sera pas une politique vaccinale
grand public compte tenu des doses
auxquelles nous aurons accès tous nos
pays et compte tenu de la stratégie
retenue et on aura vraisemblablement une
deuxième vague de vaccination qui
s'ouvrira quelque part entre avril et
juin qu'elle sera plus large et plus
grand public et qui ira vers une
stratégie de vaccination du plus grand
nombre
et là aussi il revient à chacun de me
payer de définir les règles de cette
stratégie
j'ai pu dire il ya quelques jours aux
françaises et aux français que n'auront
pas une stratégie de vaccination
obligatoire mais qu'on cherchera à
vacciner le plus grand nombre par une
stratégie de conviction et de
transparence et l'exécutif français a
par ailleurs confirmé que les résidents
des pâtes seront vaccinés en priorité la
stratégie vaccinale contrôle commis 19
devrait donc être plus rapide que prévu
la présidente de la commission
européenne ue cela van der leyen s'en
félicite
pour le moment les états membres
travaille sur les programmes de
vaccination et sur la logistique pour le
déploiement de dizaines de millions des
doses de vaccin sachez que ce n'est pas
le vaccin qui est important mais bien
les vaccinations qui sont importantes
donc si tout va bien les premiers
citoyens européens seraient peut-être et
déjà vaccinées avant la fin décembre ce
sera un grand pas en avant vers un autre
vie normale en d'autres termes il y à
bien une lumière au bout du tunnel
néanmoins nous devons encore être
discipliné jusqu'à ce que nous ayons
finalement atteint une vaccination
approprié pour éradiquer ce virus
et en attendant les fêtes de fin d'année
approchent il sera bien possible de
prendre le train ou l'avion comme l'a
confirmé aujourd'hui le ministre délégué
aux transports jean baptiste djebbari
alors avant de se retrouver en famille
quelles sont les possibilités de faire
un test coville outre le pcr naso
pharyngé tellement agréable le test
salivaire easy cover enfin reçu le feu
vert de la haute autorité de santé
pour en parler nous sommes avec
alexandra prieux directrice générale de
ce qu'il scelle bonsoir alexandre à
apprieu merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france rappelle que votre
société fait partie du consortium qui a
mis sur le marché un test salivaire de
diagnostic du coville et samedi dernier
la haute autorité de santé a enfin
autorisé ces tests j'imagine que c'est
une victoire pour vous oui en effet on
en est on en est très content c'est une
première étape qui est très importante
et ça fait plusieurs mois
qu'on travaille sur le test et plusieurs
semaines qu'on travaille activement et
qu'on discute activement avec la hs donc
bien sûr nous nous félicitons de ce de
ce résultat est de cet avis pourquoi la
haute autorité de santé at elle mis
autant de temps pour accorder cette
autorisation
alors autant de temps ça dépend de quoi
on parle
nous notre test est disponible depuis
juin mais la haute autorité de santé et
les autorités de santé en règle générale
nous ont demandé plus de résultats ce
qui était sans doute légitime d'ailleurs
et ses résultats il a fallu du temps
pour les avoir rompu les avoirs que à
partir de mi septembre date à laquelle
nous avons pu recruter des nouveaux
patients en france et à partir de là le
dialogue s'est amorcé avec la has à
partir de la fin septembre
et donc là bien sûr il faut du temps
pour que la chaise se saisissent de
dossiers et puisse bien sûr analyser
toutes les données qu'on a transmis
alors on va faire un peu de pédagogie
parce que pour le moment on connaît mal
ce test il faut préciser que l' agence
de santé est favorable à leur
utilisation uniquement pour les malades
symptomatique
c'est bien ça comme un petit peu pour
les tests antigénique tout à fait pour
le moment le test easyq off est
recommandée pour les personnes
symptomatique et surtout pour celles
pour lesquelles le prélèvement
nasopharyngé est difficile ou impossible
à réaliser 1 et s'est complètement dans
les habitudes de la chaise vous avez
cité les textes antigénique c'est
précisément ce qui s'était passé pour
ces tests hollande c'est à dire que
d'abord il y a eu une autorisation
partielle et puis petit à petit
l'autorisation peut si les données
fournies sont suffisantes être élargi et
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui s'est passé
également samedi dernier pour les tests
antigénique mais ça veut dire finalement
pour tous ces français qui auront
peut-être envie d'aller se faire tester
avant de retrouver leurs familles ça va
être peut-être compliqué à utiliser à
grande échelle parce que c'est vrai
qu'on rêve tous de faire un test très
rapide qu'on est la réponse de la
inodore incolore et dans les 20 minutes
ça sera pas possible quand on n'a pas de
symptômes en réalité alors nous on a
déjà pris date avec la chaise pour
continuer les discussions
donc la première chose qu'on va chercher
à savoir
c'est déjà de quelles informations
supplémentaires ils ont besoin et bien
sûr nous allons travailler faire notre
maximum pour fournir ces données le plus
rapidement possible et pour que
l'utilisation souhaitée l'argile le plus
rapidement possible également alors
certains chercheurs contestent les
réserves qui freine un déploiement plus
large
quelles sont ses réserves et sur quoi
sont elles fondées alors elles sont
fondées probablement sur sur un principe
de précaution qui est extrêmement
important dans tous les avis que donne
la chaîne est d'ailleurs dans certains
cas ça s'est révélé extrêmement
judicieux de le faire ensuite les
réserves sont que nos données cliniques
ont donné d'excellents résultats
donc je pense que la réaction des
scientifiques et de dire mais regardez
il ya des excellents résultats
donc pourquoi attendre alors pourquoi
attendre
les français vont peut-être se poser la
question et auront donc envie de venir
se faire tester comment ça va se passer
un peu partout en france est-ce que ça
va être facile d'accès ces tests
salivaires
alors pour le moment ne sais pas encore
parce que on attend encore l'arrêté
ministériel qui va nous expliquer
comment on va pouvoir pouvoir faire les
choses il ya plusieurs options qui sont
possibles mais si on prend comme
comparaison le test antigénique dans ce
cas là c'est très facile puisque là on
peut le faire a énormément d'endroits
par exemple dans les pharmacies et à
titre personnel bien sûr j'espère que ce
sera possible dans un très grand nombre
d'endroits et en particulier dans l'es8
pharmaciens donc ça veut dire que pour
le moment voilà il faut encore attendre
celle affaire de quelques semaines où ça
va s'enchaîner dans la foulée ce décret
ministériel en général ses fans au
ministère de la santé est extrêmement
réactif que ce genre de choses donc nous
espérons l'avoir dans un très petit
nombre de jours et donc ils dès ce
moment là nous on s'est préparés et on
pourra réagir en conséquence
alors il ya deux questions évidemment
très importante et ce seront les
dernières la question de la fiabilité
parce que c'est toujours la question
qu'on se pose lorsqu'on fait un test pcr
antigénique ou autre et
dernière question à ce qu'ils seront
remboursés alors l'avis de la has
préconise également un remboursement
donc si le ministère suit l'avis de la
chaîne alors le test devrait être
remboursé en ce qui concerne la
fiabilité
nous avons émis hier un communiqué de
presse avec nos partenaires du cnrs et
du chu de montpellier et les résultats
de l'étude clinique qui sont donc à
décrits dans ce communiqué de presse
dans une sensibilité de 87% et une
spécificité de 99% donc des résultats
qui ont satisfait largement les membres
du du consortium que nous avons fournis
ça veut dire donc ce pourcentage
effectués sur sur des personnes qui
présentent des symptômes
alors non nous on a fait une étude
clinique qui était plus large que ça
déjà ce qu'on a voulu faire c'est se
placer dans un cas réel de dépistage ou
qu'est ce qu'on a fait on est allé au
chu de montpellier et puis on est allés
au drive c'est à dire quelque chose qui
est tout à fait standard et au drive et
bien vous avez je dirais un petit peu
tout le monde
vous avez bien sûr des patients
symptomatiques vous avez des cas
contacts et vous avez des patients
asymptomatiques
et donc on retrouve cette population
d'un autre état clinique c'est-à-dire sa
femme dans notre étude clinique pardon
c'est à dire des patients symptomatiques
et des patients asymptomatiques
merci beaucoup alexandre à apprieu
directrice générale de skills elle alors
que le test isikoff salivaire a donc
reçu l'autorisation de la haute autorité
de la santé merci à vous c'était donc il
y a un an le coronavirus faisait son
apparition chine l'épidémie qui s'est
très vite propagé pour mettre toute la
planète au ralenti alors que la course
au vaccin se poursuit l'om est
aujourd'hui de retracer les origines de
ce virus qui reste encore bien
mystérieuse pierre yens mazayes il ya un
peu plus d'un nom un mystérieux virus
est détecté dans la ville chinoise de
wuhan
très vite le sar skov de envahi le monde
entier et soulève de multiples
interrogations
d'où vient-il qu'en est il exactement
apparu
si sa provenance demeure incertaine la
communauté scientifiques estiment que
l'animal à l'origine du virus serait la
chauve souris
celle ci aurait transmis le sar skov de
o pango l'un un petit mammifère
d'afrique et d'asie du sud-est qu'il
aurait à son tour transmis à l'homme
mais d'autres théories souvent
controversées circulent au printemps
dernier donald trump le martelait que le
coc vie 19 avaient pu accidentellement
s'échapper d'un laboratoire de houran
notre pays comme la france reproche à
pékin un manque de transparence sur sa
gestion de l'épidémie
des accusations démenties par la chine
pour les milieux complotistes le virus
aurait même été créé volontairement en
laboratoire des théories balayé par
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
l'instance internationale appelle à se
baser uniquement sur la recherche
scientifique
nous voulons connaître l'origine du
virus et nous ferons tout pour cela s'il
vous plaît ne politisent et pas cette
question
nous faisons tout ce que nous pouvons en
nous appuyant sur la science ce qui a
constitué un obstacle et ceux qui a
tenté de nous éloigner de ce que nous
avons fait scientifiquement c'est la
politisation de l'étude de l'origine du
virus par certains lots oms espèrent
envoyer le plus vite possible une équipe
internationale d'études à bourg ain pour
comprendre comment l'épidémie à démarré
et prévenir d'autres introductions de
virus dans la population humaine
c'est une affaire devenue le symbole de
la lutte contre les violences policières
adama traoré est mort et il ment or à
cause d'une interpellation musclée en
2016 dans ce dossier riche en
rebondissements judiciaires et justice
annule une des expertises médicales
dédouanant les gendarmes
une expertise annulé pour vice de
procédure c'est maître yassine à moudre
aux avocats de la famille qui a déposé
une requête en nullité
deux ans après la mort de zyed redouane
à marseille lors d'une manifestation de
gilet jaune une contre enquête met en
cause les conclusions du rapport
d'expertisé officiel elle valide la
thèse d'un tir tendu provenant et crs et
engage la responsabilité de la police
n'a déjà des razak
oui pas qu'on laisse penser que les
forces de l'ordre ont tué in ebre
douanes parce que c'est faux pas aussi
faux que ça à en croire la contre
expertise menée par le site
d'investigation disclose et le cabinet
fort ainsi qu'architecture l' enquête
démontre que la responsabilité de la
police est plus que jamais engagée
c'était il ya tout juste deux ans le 1er
décembre 2018 lors d'une manifestation
de gilet jaune à marseille zineb
redouane 80 ans est touché par une
grenade de gaz lacrymogène alors qu'elle
refermer les volets de son appartement
situé au 4e étage
grièvement blessé au visage elle décède
le lendemain à l'hôpital
et très vite la police est pointé du
doigt traumatisme général au sein de
notre homme avec les propos qu'on a vu
de la mer mais zizou c'est très souvent
c'est pour ça qu'on veut que justice
soit faite rapidement la justice bafouée
dans les premiers temps et après de
nombreux couacs la sphère est dépaysé à
lyon en août 2019
suite à des soupçons de collusion entre
le parquet de marseille et les policiers
mis en cause sur les cinq policiers
porteurs d'un lance grenade au moment
des faits aucun n'a reconnu son
implication et en mai 2020 un rapport
balistique remis
à la justice comprenant l'analyse de
vidéos de surveillance par exemple
disculper la police larmes a été utilisé
selon les préconisations les procédures
d'emploi en vigueur dans la police
nationale
sauf qu'une reconstitution vidéo de la
scène a réalisé par disclose efforts
ainsi qu'architecture démontrerait
aujourd'hui le contraire le policier
aurait utilisé son arme un lance grenade
de type cougar de manière non
réglementaire selon le texte encadrant
l'usagé de cet équipement le tir tendu
est strictement interdite afin d'éviter
que les personnes soient directement
impactés autrement dit le tir doit
suivre une trajectoire parabolique dit
en cloche et le document de préciser il
incombe aux porteurs de larmes
d'apprécier la trajectoire de la grenade
et d'envisager le point d'explosion ou
d'impact pourtant depuis sa position et
en adoptant un angle de tir compris
entre 30 et 45 degrés le policier dirige
forcément son arme vers la façade d'un
des immeubles situés devant lui une
dizaine de fenêtres se trouve
potentiellement sur la trajectoire de sa
grenade un tir non adaptés et dangereux
fatal à zinab red one qui succombent de
ses blessures le lendemain
dans les faits le projectile a heurté la
partie supérieure du corps de zineb
redouane au bout de 37 m
les expertises balistiques précise que
l'impact a eu lieu dans la phase encore
montante de la trajectoire à une vitesse
de 97,2 km heure la violence du choc a
provoqué un fracas de l'ensemble de la
partie droite du visage de l'octogénaire
la victime a également inhalé une très
grande quantité de gaz lacrymogènes
la grenade mp7 étant prévu pour évacuer
un espace extérieur d'environ 1000 m² au
lendemain de la publication de cette
contre-enquête la famille annonce porter
plainte devant la cour de justice de la
république contre christophe castaner
pour altération et soustraction de
preuves
le ministre de l'intérieur de l'époque
avait déclaré que la victime était morte
d'un choc opératoire et non un choc
faciale et carton donc toute
responsabilité des crs dans quelques
instants nous parlerons du haut karabagh
environ 2000 soldats russes de maintien
de la paix sont sur place pour garantir
l'accord de cessez-le-feu
et puis direction l'iran téhéran qui
continue d'accuser israël d'avoir
assassiné le scientifique mort scène sa
grillade est le physicien eu droit à des
funérailles nationales hier
[Musique]
que s'est il passé entre juillet dernier
la mi novembre pour que la hongrie puis
la pologne
tous deux sont tenues à part la slovénie
décident d'imposer leur veto au plan de
relance de l'union européenne les
européens ont décidé de mettre en place
ce qu'on appelle une clause de
conditionnalité c'est à dire il
conditionne ses versements au respect de
certaines mesures de l'état de droit
c'est l'europe qui dit nous allons
décider pour vous et nous allons nous
immiscer on ne peut pas avoir une
juridiction en fait plus haute que les
vôtres ils sont anti européen de toulon
date c'est bien connu et donc ils sont
dans une posture aussi je pense que ils
vont très rapidement cédé sur ces points
là parce qu'ils ont besoin de cet argent
pour qu'ils disent non alors que c'est
les principaux bénéficiaires de ce plan
de relance
ça peut bien dire qu'il ya un vrai souci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'état islamique a recruté dans toutes
les couches de la société sans faire de
tri des mineurs des femmes des
délinquants des criminels de droit
commun tout le monde est venu à jaca en
syrie il ya encore quelques quelques
années au moment de charlie hebdo
clou du bataclan il y avait un état
islamiste qui semblait diriger tout ça
la bascule et se fait justement en 2015
et smith est un peu le passage de relais
d'al qaïda l'état islamique
quelques pas dans notre politique
internationale il est bien évident qu'il
faut pas créer les conditions à nouveau
une terre de jihad et de cet appel d'air
justement au recrutement l'a
malheureusement fait en syrie en irak
[Musique]
un des sujets les plus préoccupants du
moment et celui de l'otan et de la
défense
tout au long des années l'alliance
atlantique s'est investi dans des
guerres qui n'étaient pas toujours
réellement en ligne avec ses objectifs
traduit la situation s'est aggravée avec
le début d' attaque contre la très gâte
courbet et 10 juillet les mots nations
contre la grèce et la présence de thua
d'ist syriens venus dit libre haut
karabakh
incapable de régler ses conflits
internes le temps est devenu un frein
politique à l'unité européenne
c'est à l'europe d'être en capacité
d'assumer la responsabilité de sa propre
sécurité et d'agir de manière autonome
quand c'est nécessaire
mais compte tenu des divergences avec
quelle europe pourront nous le faire
[Musique]
le nombre de contaminés au plomb de
chaque semaine je pense que le système
des chu est à bout de souffle
si on ne réforme pas dans les prochaines
années mais si un jour on va continuer
notre des plates le gouvernement ait
finalement pris entre deux feux il
s'agit là d'éviter une crise économique
et en même temps d'hésiter à la
propagation du virus à jour répètent à
la place du gouvernement français en ce
moment car hier que des mauvaises
solutions
ce que des gens comme moi propose en ce
moment c'est que à la fin du confinement
on teste 60 millions de français
si on continue comme on fait là moi j'ai
un peu peur pour décoincer jusqu'à la
fin janvier
[Musique]
21h30 heure française soyez les
bienvenus si vous nous rejoignez en
direct sur rt fransson la situation dans
le haut karabagh et les forces
azerbaïdjanaises qui sont entrés cette
nuit dans le district de latchine
derrière dernière des trois provinces
concernées par les rétrocessions de
l'arménie certains habitants
irréductibles refusent de partir sous la
surveillance toujours étroite des
soldats russes walid bennani des soldats
au garde-à-vous posant fièrement devant
le drapeau de l'azerbaïdjan le ministère
azerbaïdjanais de la défense n'a pas
tardé à dévoiler ses images dans la
région dissidents du haut karabagh le
district de latchine passer désormais
sous pavillon azéri défilé de voitures
les couleurs bleu rouge et verte
il s'est fièrement sous le regard
méfiant de la population locale certains
ne sont pas prêts d'ailleurs à quitter
leurs terres ces moines lot
nous continuerons à vivre ici nous avons
un supermarché un modèle et une maison
nous allons les développer continue à
vivre ici comme nous l'avons fait
auparavant
nous n'allons rien donner à personne il
y aura des difficultés mais nous les
surmonterons et je ramènerai ma famille
nous vivront ici tout ira bien
s'accommoder d'un accord de paix sous
l'égide de la russie
les soldats russes bien présent et des
plus prudents notre mission est
d'assurer la sécurité des civils qui
conduisent leur véhicule dans le
corridor de latchine nous disposons d'un
registre spécial dans lequel nous
inscrivons l'heure de passage et le
nombre de passagers
nous assurons également la sécurité tout
au long du corridor
après le district de calva jarre celui
d'agdam c'est au tour d'une zone des
plus stratégiques d'être rétrocéder à
l'azerbaïdjan au sein du district de
latchine se trouve donc le corridor de
latchine une bande de terre de 5 km de
large qui relie l'arménie le haut
karabagh où la libre circulation est
garantie par les forces russes
les militaires azéri célébré aujourd'hui
dans leur pays
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une nouvelle réalité est apparu dans
notre région c'est nous qui avons créé
cette réalité l'azerbaïdjan a créé cette
réalité nous avons chassé l'ennemi de
notaire au total dans ce conflit les
séparatistes du haut karabagh ont
rétrocédé sept districts près de 2000
soldats russes du maintien de la paix
ont été déployés dans la région
unité médicale hôpital de campagne
sans oublier des travaux de déminage
compliqué ce mardi le ministère turc de
la défense a annoncé également la
signature d'un accord avec la russie sur
l'établissement d'un centre conjointe
d'observation le but surveiller le
cessez le feu dans la région
l accord de paix signé le 9 novembre a
fait toujours grincer des dents du côté
français également les sénateurs ont
voté la semaine dernière une résolution
demandant à l'exécutif de reconnaître la
république du haut karabagh alors
comment juger cette initiative est une
faute politique comme certains le disent
c'est l'objet de notre face à face ce
soir
[Musique]
et pour en débattre nous sommes avec
christian cambon sénateur les
républicains du val de marne vous êtes
également christian cambon président de
la commission des affaires étrangères au
sénat merci d'être avec nous à vos côtés
jérôme lambert député ps vice président
du groupe d'amitié interparlementaire
france azerbaïdjan bonsoir à vous aussi
merci d'être là alors c'est un vin qui a
provoqué la colère du président
azerbaïdjanais ilham aliev qui a peu
goûté évidemment la position des
sénateurs français avant d'en débattre
vous propose d'écouter sa réaction
aujourd'hui l'un des pays situés à des
milliers de kilomètres adopte des lois
leur parlement discute de cette question
qu'est ce que le parlement français à
avoir avec notre question depuis combien
d'années la france est-elle coprésidente
du groupe de minsk at elle fait quelque
chose at-elle pris les mesures concrètes
pour résoudre ce problème
maintenant une fois le problème résolu
vous regardez ce qui se passe le sénat
français adopte une résolution vous
connaître le haut karabagh si vous les
aimez
alors comme je les dis pendant la bière
donné leur ville de marseille changer
son nom et leur un deuxième état là bas
mais personne ne peut s'immiscer dans
les affaires des provocations évidemment
de la part du président azéri mais on
entend surtout beaucoup de colère et en
clair mêlez vous de vos affaires
christian cambon une réaction écoutez je
crois qu'effectivement le sénat est
d'abord le parlement français délibère
sur ses seules initiatives et n'a pas
besoin d'instructions particulières d'un
responsable
étrangers quels qu'ils soient je
comprends très bien que le président
aliyev et n'est pas très bien réagi à
cette initiative mais aussi bien à
l'assemblée nationale qu'au sénat le
pouvoir de voter des résolutions qui ne
sont pas des lois
c'est une manière tout à fait
parlementaire est bien connue d'exprimer
la position des groupes
j'observe que cette résolution a été
adoptée par 305 voix contre une et
encore notre collègue avoué qu'elle
s'était trompée donc que ses 305 sur 348
vous voyez le consensus +2 je crois que
ces cinq ou six groupes allant de la
droite à la gauche se sont associés ça
veut dire quelque chose ça veut dire
qu'effectivement le parlement et
singulièrement le sénat a pris une
initiative en réponse aux événements qui
se sont déroulés au karabagh c'est aussi
un signe d'amitié que nous avons adressé
à l'arménie avec lesquels nous avons des
liens anciens historique est privilégiée
et c'est aussi un une manière de dire au
gouvernement français agissez car
contrairement à ce que dit monsieur
aliyev
la france est coprésidente du groupe de
minsk avec les états unis et avec la
russie ya donc nous avons des
responsabilités et ce qui se passe dans
cette région du caucase nous concerne
tous
voilà quand des régions stratégie
géopolitique et donc nous avions à dire
comme nous l'avons redis encore hier à
l'ambassadeur de turquie que nous avons
reçus avec le président larcher
nous l'avons nous avons dit qu'il y
avait un certain nombre de choses qui ne
nous plaisait pas et c'est le libre
droit du parlement jusqu'à preuve du
contraire dans des pays démocratiques de
s'exprimer comme il l'entend voilà alors
côté arménien le vote du sénat aussi
fait réagir mais évidemment pas du tout
sur le même registre je vous propose
avant de donner la parole à nikol
pashinian d'écouter la réaction du
premier ministre à la arménien j'adresse
ma profonde gratitude de la france et où
peuple français pour la résolution du
sénat sur la reconnaissance de la
république d'artsakh la france qui
affirme son attachement aux valeurs
universelles ainsi qu'au respect des
principes fondamentaux du droit
international alors jérôme lambert
évidemment réaction beaucoup plus posé
de la part de nikol pashinian vous
comprenez vous ce ce vote du sénat qui
devient la première instance un tout de
même officielle dans le monde à
reconnaître la république autoproclamée
du haut karabagh même l'arménie ne
reconnaît pas cette entité quelle
cohérence je vous le dites vous-même
vous m'aviez pas beaucoup de cohérence
dans tout ça d'abord le sénat nous
reconnaît pas le sénat demande par un
certain nombre de 28 mais enfin il faut
signaler que les sénateurs absence elles
sont leurs groupes qui votent à leur
place c'est pour ça qu'il ya eu beaucoup
de votants mais tous les sénateurs
étaient présents et effectivement le
scénar a souhaité que le gouvernement
français reconnaissent la république du
haut karabagh mais c'est pas une
reconnaissance en soit la reconnaissance
on sait pas si elle interviendra vais
vous savez que les résolutions moi je
suis parlementaire depuis fort longtemps
comme mon collègue délit est aussi
sénateur depuis un moment des
résolutions j'en ai voté quelques unes
je me souviens d'en avoir une
à quelques années pour quitter
d'inspiration et l'air aussi qu'ils
étaient pour demander la levée des
sanctions à l'encontre de la russie à
propos d'eux des événements dans
l'ukraine et au crime et et nous avions
voté cette résolution l'assemblée
nationale il savait bien malheureusement
je l'avais voter dégâts et vous savez
bien que malheureusement ces sanctions à
l'encontre de la russie existe encore
donc c'est vous dire la portée des
résolutions que nous par notre parlement
le sénat comme l'assemblée nationale
veut voter donc on va bien voir mais en
réalité ce sont des signaux politiques
mais ce n'est pas mais ce n'est pas une
je dirais une action qu'ils aient un
rapport avec le droit international en
tout cas
ça change rien la position de la france
ni au droit international et pourtant
jérôme lambert
c'est vrai que tout le monde 1 les deux
parties des deux camps on le voit dans
toutes les réflexions tout le monde on
appelle au droit international christian
cambon comme si chacun était convaincu
d'avoir le droit international avec lui
dans cette affaire
écoutez le droit international en
l'occurrence est une chose suffisamment
compliqué je pense que c'est pas
exactement sous cet angle que les choses
se passent d'abord je confirme ce que
vient de dire mon collègue de
l'assemblée jérôme lambert
le sénat a invité le gouvernement c'est
pas le sénat n'a aucun pouvoir pour en
connaître un pays que je précise ce
point c'est une résolution c'est
l'expression libre des groupes
politiques qui utilisent ce mode
d'action ce mode d'expression plus
exactement
et donc je pense qu'il faut lui donner
la signification qui la signification
elle et elle est politique c'est vrai il
ya eu une forte émotion au scénar je
pense que c'est aussi à l'assemblée
puisque j'ai l'impression que à
l'assemblée il ya une initiative qui se
prépare à peu près identique en tous les
cas dans des termes à peu près
identiques émanant de la majorité
sénateur de la majorité à l'assemblée
nationale et qui doit venir en
discussion je crois moi décembre et qui
vise effectivement à s'exprimer sur
cette sur cette situation
le la sphère du haut karabagh est une
affaire très ancienne et on va pas dans
un débat comme ce soir régler ce
problème mais si on avait trouvé la
solution il ya belle lurette que ce
serait déjà réglé je rappelle
effectivement que nos diplomates et pas
et parmi les meilleurs du reste depuis
20 ans iej dans ce groupe de minsk et
que jusqu'à présent c'est un fait
aucune solution n'a pu être pu être
identifié justement sur le plan du droit
international et des négociations il ya
peut-être des responsabilités qui sont
tout à fait partagé vous avez dans ce
genre d'affaires c'est pas au tout noir
d'un côté tout blanc de l'autre en
revanche ce qui nous a particulièrement
ému c'est justement des déclarations
telles que le président aliyev en a fait
en dix ans nous avons enfin chassé chez
ses chiens alors quand on signe un
protocole de cessez le feu et que l'on
invite après les populations à revenir
dans dans les lieux en question bon ce
sont des termes qui me semble assez peu
favorables à l'établissement de la paix
et c'est parce que nous craignons
beaucoup pour la survie physique la
survie physique de debug des populations
arméniennes du haut karabakh
moi je sais j'ai fait projeter devant la
commission
des affaires étrangères des documents
que je tiens à la disposition de nos
collègues et qui montre avec quelle
sauvagerie les choses se sont passées
puisque nous avons la certitude que des
militants des miliciens islamistes se
sont se sont participer à ces opérations
et ont utilisé des procédés qui sont
absolument épouvantable des têtes
coupées des organes coupe et c'est donc
la france encore une fois pour tout un
tas de raisons civilisationnel
historique que sais-je
ce que l'arménie a consenti pour les
libertés en france aussi on pourrait le
rappeler nous avons ce lien là et je
pense que l'expression du sénat qui a
été conduit sous l'autorité du président
du sénat qui avait souhaité que les
groupes puissent exprimer de manière
commune dont je crois que c'est
effectivement et nous revendiquons cette
expression politique en disant s'il y a
des s'il ya des problèmes il ya d'autres
manières de les régler alors pour
l'instant nous n'avons pas et c'est pas
nous qui sommes aux manettes pour
trouver la solution politique
mais dans cette résolution il ya
beaucoup de considérants et nous
demandons justement au gouvernement de
tout faire pour utiliser pour réanimer
en quelque sorte ce groupe de huit
est-ce que vous est ce que vous vous
souvenez tous de même que le
cessez-le-feu a été signé alors que la
france n'a même pas été informés bon bon
il ya des milliards des méthodes qui
sont quand même un tout petit peu
compliqué on a eu l'occasion de le dire
à nos collègues russes je pense que le
gouvernement français l'a fait le
président de la république aussi du
reste qui s'entretient tente avec
monsieur pashinian qu'avec monsieur
alief mais le parlement fait ce qu'il
croit devoir faire dans cette affaire il
ya une dimension humanitaire y ait une
dimension cultuelle et culturelle
je suis très heureux que depuis ces
événements ainsi si hâtive été pris par
l'unesco pour sauvegarder un certain
nombre de lieux de culte chrétiens
voilà des sujets qui ont pu animer des
groupes aussi différents que le groupe
communiste le groupe
le groupe centriste le groupe socialiste
firent collègues étaient totalement anja
terre et donc voilà je pense qu'on a été
dans notre dans notre droit et pas
toujours en fonction du droit
international car c'est une affaire très
compliquée là la russie effectivement
tout qui était très intéressé par la
préservation de ces lieux culturels
puisque sa figure de dents dans l'accord
jérôme lambert vous vous offusquez vous
de ne pas avoir été prévenus en tant que
français voilà degré cet accord
l'urgence n'était pas plutôt la paix
avant toute chose puisqu'on fait
référence à l'humanitaire justement
l'option c'était à la paix mon collègue
ali beaucoup de choses j'ai noté j'ai eu
aussi noté un certain point certains
points
le droit international c'est compliqué
le droit international mon cher collègue
vous êtes président de la commission des
affaires étrangères et de la défense au
sénat
certes c'est compliqué mais le droit
international demeure leurs eaux
internationales
le président de la république notre
président la république a rappelé que le
haut karabagh a été un territoire azéri
il l'a rappelé il ya quelques jours
donc c'est compliqué non pas tant que ça
il faut tout simplement respecter le
droit international
quel sera l'avenir du haut karabagh et
bien le haut karabakh est un territoire
azerbaïdjanais
reconnu par les institutions
internationales ont reconnu par la
france comme étant un territoire
azerbaïdjanais
reconnu par la france depuis 1993 un
certain nombre de résolutions des
nations unies
sur la route la tester des résolutions
qui n'ont jamais été remis en cause qui
a été voté sous la présidence de
françois mitterrand mais que jacques
chirac n'a pas remis en cause que
nicolas sarkozy n'a pas remis en cause
que françois hollande n'a pas remis en
cause que emmanuel macron ne remet pas
en cause
donc en fait on cherche aujourd'hui à
faire une histoire de franco française
parce qu'en réalité même l'arménie vous
l'avez rappelé tout à l'heure n'a pas
reconnu l'indépendance du haut-karabakh
et nous en france on est un certain
nombre d'élus qui guidera ballet
faudrait alors on s'émeut de certaines
images certes c'est la guerre et c'est
vrai que ces images qu'on a tous vu son
émouvante mais vous savez bien
malheureusement on en a autant des deux
côtés c'est à dire on se demande
d'ailleurs
si ces images sont vraies si ce sont pas
des images fabriquées compris des vidéos
ou fabriqués savait depuis le temps que
on a vu et les armes de destruction
massives entraîné le monde dans la
guerre parce que il y avait des preuves
de ces armes de destruction massive
alors maintenant quand on me parle me
table ne montre jamais vraiment bien des
choses
on me parle de d'éléments de djihadistes
et tout ça deux de tête recoupées avec
des photos écouter tous à une trêve
malheureux mais moi j'ai plutôt tendance
à me dire qu'en temps de guerre
l'information c'est avant tout de la
propagande et la propagande on lui fait
dire ce que l'on vous les deux côtés un
et deux côtés mais là il se trouve que
ça penche du côté de l'arménie puisqu'en
l'occurrence ce sont avec ses arguments
là que certains s'émeuvent ses mavs en
france de ce mal de tête ailleurs dans
le monde mais je vois qu'il faut pas
parce qu'on était mue par des images de
guerre
fabriqué à fabriquer mais enfin des
images de guerre
il faut pas jeter aux orties le droit
international le droit international dit
clairement que le territoire du haut
karabagh est administrée doit être
administré la totalité à terme par
l'azerbaïdjan
il faudra faire avec et on va essayer on
va essayer le rôle de la france c'est
d'essayer de faire en sorte que ça se
passe bien
et pour ça il faut pas été exclu du
groupe de mise pour quoi on en serait
exclu
pourquoi parce que jusqu'à présent nous
avions une position neutre en quelque
sorte on essaye on était l'ami des
azerbaïdjanais est l'ami des arméniens
tout le monde nous reconnaissait cette
qualité les russes les arméniens les
azerbaïdjanais tout le monde pour ça
qu'on avait cette place là justement
jours pardonnez moi parce qu'il faut
donner le mot de la fin pardonnez-moi
jérôme lambert on a compris en substance
l'idée il faut donner le mot de la fin
christian cambon on arrive à la fin
justement ceux qui vous disent
aujourd'hui finalement c'est un aveu
d'impuissance et même une faute
politique
il y avait un chercheur directeur
adjoint de l'iris un didier billion qui
disait ça d'impuissance de la part de
notre pays
même faute politique de la part du sénat
qu'est ce que vous répondez ce sera le
mot de la fin question qu'en bon mais je
conteste tout à fait l'interprétation de
faute politique encore une fois aussi
bien jérôme lambert a tout à fait raison
de dire qu'il ya bien sûr du droit
international il la reconnaissance du
fait que c'était sûr que le
haut-karabakh ce site et sur un
territoire azerbaïdjanais
mais manifestement cette solution qui
date de la fin de la guerre 1991 à 1994
ne ne solutionne pas le problème puisque
les incidents ne cessent de se
multiplier
nous savons et je pense que jérôme
lambert le sait donc ce sont des
situations qui date d'une création par
staline on connaît toute cette histoire
et ça ne correspond pas effectivement à
la réalité telle qu'elle est vécue par
les populations et donc on ne tombe pas
dans une dent dans un excès d'émotion
on sait simplement exprimé comme le
parlement a le droit de le faire et
c'est le gouvernement français n'est pas
mêlé à ça il siégeait à son banc et il
fera bien ce qu'il voudra et on il n'est
pas question de le contester et moi je
suis sur la ligne de jérôme lambert à
savoir je souhaite que le gouvernement
prenne des initiatives
on avait l'impression sans merci en tout
cas à tous les deux merci beaucoup
monsieur cambon et lambert d'avoir
accepté de participer à ce débat sur rt
france
circonstances toujours floues autour de
la mort du scientifique iranien mohsen
fakhrizadeh assassiné vendredi l'iran
accuse israël et ses services secrets
aucun commentaire pour l'heure de l'état
hébreu david khalifa un hommage digne
des plus grands martyrs de la république
islamique mohsen fakhrizadeh mort suite
à une attaque à la voiture piégée
vendredi a eu droit à des funérailles
nationales
un public limité composée
essentiellement de militaires les
ennemis doivent le savoir ceci est leur
première défaite
si leur objectif était de tuer notre
cher martyrs pour faire oublier son nom
désormais son nom est louée par tous et
il est devenu une idole pour tous ceux
qui s'engagent sur la voie du combat
la cérémonie teintée d'émotion a laissé
place à un sentiment de revanche sur
leur ennemi juré israël comme un symbole
le cercueil du scientifique a été déposé
dans un important sanctuaire chiite dans
le nord de téhéran où reposent deux
autres scientifiques assassiné en 2010
et en 2011
l'iran a pointé du doigt israël dans ces
meurtres précédent comme dans celui ci
la nation iranienne est trop intelligent
pour tomber dans le piège de la
conspiration mise en place par les
sionistes
il pense à créer le chaos mais ils
devraient savoir que nous les avons
démasqués et qu'ils ne réussiront pas à
atteindre leurs objectifs maléfique des
accusations restées pour l'instant sans
réponse
benyamin nétanyahou sur les réseaux
sociaux est resté évasif
pourtant sur ces images tournées en 2018
le premier ministre israélien mentionne
le nom de ce scientifique tués lors
d'une conférence de presse sur les
dangers du nucléaire iranien et ce n'est
pas tout la responsabilité de l'état
hébreu prendre l'ampleur avec ses
déclarations d'un responsable israélien
à new york
times ce samedi il affirme que le monde
devrait remercier l'état hébreu une
formule reprise par l'ancien ministre
israélien de la défense
encore une fois je n'ai aucune idée de
ce qu'il a fait ce que je peux dire
c'est pourquoi cela s'est produit et
pourquoi il est important et essentiel
d'arrêter cet effort continu massif de
militarisation nucléaire si on se
réveille un matin dans un monde où
téhéran possède 2 305 armes nucléaires
ce nouveau monde sera terrible si ce
sera un cauchemar pour tout le monde
pour les états unis pour la russie pour
tous c'est quelque chose que le monde
doit arrêter les autorités iraniennes
accusent également les moudjahidine du
peuple un groupe d'opposition en exil
d'être derrière ce complot
en tout cas cet attentat vient remettre
de l'huile sur le feu dans les relations
entre les etats-unis et l'iran joe biden
souhaite changer de cap
faire revivre l'accord de vienne par le
dialogue pour un gel des recherches
nucléaires
sauf qu'en attendant la passation de
pouvoir donald trump et benyamin
netanyahou souhaite pousser leurs
adversaires dans ses limites
l'iran entre deux eaux doit choisir
entre des exigences de vengeance et une
volonté opportuniste de sortir de son
isolement et pour en parler nous sommes
avec thierry coville chercheur à l'iris
institut des relations internationales
et stratégiques bonsoir thierry coville
merci d'être avec nous alors pour bien
qu'on comprenne quel rôle exact joué ce
scientifique
d'après ce qu'on sait où il était
responsable de la militarisation du
programme nucléaire iranien qui a sans
doute eu lieu à la fin des années 90 et
qui s'est sans doute arrêté au début de
celle et demi et il voit là aider et ils
devraient justement qui pouvait être un
potentiel danger avec voilà c'est
programme nucléaire qu'il aurait
développé ses programmes militaires
c'est juste berlin où le narratif que je
viens d'entendre le pose problème parce
que ce qu'on sait c'est 'qui l'iran a eu
l'intention de construire la bombe
atomique
mais ce qu'on sait aussi et je crois que
c'est même les tous les services secrets
américains qui avaient mis en commun
leurs informations
ils ont sans doute arrêter la mite la
militarisation de la preuve les efforts
de militarisation de leur programme donc
l'heure d'avant déconstruire bombe
atomique
vers 2003 deuxièmement l'iran a quand
même signé cet accord sur le nucléaire
de 2015 qui donne la garantie que le
programme nucléaire iranien reste
pacifique jusqu'en 2025 avec un vous le
rappelez quand même pas dans cet accord
c'est un contrôle continu des
inspecteurs de l'agencé de l'énergie
atomique qui vérifie que le programme
nucléaire est pacifique donc oui il
était important parce qu'il a aidé à la
construction d'une bombe fait un projet
de constituer un beau match mais en fin
des années 90 mais le programme
nucléaire iranien
depuis l'accord de 2015 on a des
garanties qu'il est de nature pacifique
est-ce qu'il constituait réellement
potentiellement un danger pour l'état
hébreu
vous parlez du de sélectionner fiq
oui ça va être sous laissez moi je ne
crois pas d'ailleurs vous parliez des
assassinats de deux scientifiques
iraniens dont je crois en 2010 2011 le
programme nucléaire iranien c'est je
sais pas combien je dirais des centaines
de deux spécialistes de physique
nucléaire en iran
c'est pas une seule personne c'est un
effort continu depuis des années donc je
crois pas qu'il soit lié à une personne
d'ailleurs je me rappelle bien quand
j'ai vu l'assassinât de ces
scientifiques
le nombre de scientifiques
centrifugeuses à la fin du mandat
d'ahmadinejad en 2013 il avait fortement
augmenté en iran donc c'est le
le programme nucléaire iranien il dépend
pas dessus de cette personne même si
elles étaient elles vêpres ou de savoir
si c'est beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d'ingénieurs qui ont fait des formations
physique nucléaire qui travaillent dans
ce programme donc c'est pas une seule
personne et pourtant l'iran affirme que
ce scientifique aurait été victime donc
d'une opération complexe impliquant des
moyens complètement nouveau de la part
de l'état hébreu de quoi s'agit-il
rapidement s'il vous plaît parce que
malheureusement nous arrivons à la fin
de cette émission je suis absolument pas
spécialiste des questions militaires
dont on parle dans tous les cas pour
mener ce type d'opération au plein coeur
de téhéran effectivement c'était
complexe est clair merci en tout cas
thierry coville de nous avoir apporté
votre éclairage et c'est la fin de cette
émission se retrouve dans quelques
minutes à 22 heures pour un point
complet sur l'actualité
[Musique]